there's a guy canvassing for Marco Rubio
and Ronda santis in Florida and he was
mercilessly beaten that's what Marco
Rubio reports and now we have some more
confirmation on this individual
apparently it was in a Democrat County
when four individuals said you are not
welcome here and then mercilessly beat
him to the point where he's got internal
bleeding he's going to need facial
reconstructive surgery and it's a pretty
it's a pretty crazy story The response
we've seen from the left is that they're
saying this guy is apparently associated
with fascists and we have a report from
I believe it's Miami Times talking about
how he's posted a bunch of race and
offensive things and it's interesting
because seeing someone go out in canvas
for politically and then to be
mercilessly beaten and the response is
he's a bad guy and I'm like well you
know I'd agree those opinions are really
awful the things he was saying is that
supposed to wash away or Justify the
fact that he's going to need facial
reconstructive surgery he's got internal
bleeding and the violence is escalating
to an extreme degree this is crazy stuff
man and I'll tell you why they're so
threatened by him we just finished
watching as many of you may have the
debate between DeSantis and Christ in
Florida and I just got to say I think
that I think DeSantis absolutely crushed
Chris in this debate he made a lot of
really great points people were
screaming and yelling some people didn't
like DeSantis but it was really
interesting so we'll talk about that
we've got a bunch of other stories too
this one's surprising Joe Biden is
actually calling he's he's condemning
the dangerous gain of function research
being done at Boston University so I was
actually surprised to see that but of
course we gotta talk about Ted Cruz
getting interrupted by climate change
activists on The View man these people
are these activists for the left they're
actually helping the Republican party
because gas prices are one of the
biggest issues if not the biggest right
now before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
to support our work click that beautiful
little join us button and as a member
you'll get access to the timcast IRL
uncensored show Monday through Thursday
at 11 PM Plus the entire massive Library
I think there's hundreds of episodes now
or 500 you'll definitely want to check
that out because I had a bunch of really
awesome people you'll get to watch the
cast Castle Vlog Tales from the very
World we've got new shows coming and you
will be supporting our journalists we
had a reporter on the ground at Matt
Walsh's event we've got a reporter on
the ground uh covering a lot of these
events as they're starting to take shape
with the midterms coming up so don't
forget to also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us to talk
about all of this and more is Lisa
Reynolds hi guys I'm happy to be back
thanks for having me Tim who are you oh
my gosh
um I guess a long time political Insider
I just uh left a really long stint on
the hill and I'm working in political
Consulting and freelance writing so
right on yeah you work for anybody
interesting nothing I want to say on
here all right so a couple people couple
interesting people all right well cool a
couple interesting people yeah right on
thanks for hanging out we've also got
Lou gradkowski now you get all quiet uh
you guys are in for quite a show my name
is Luke radowski here of we are
change.org and the shirt I'm wearing
today is a little bit uh on the nose
it's a 2024 Joe Biden shirt and uh
family friendly it is it is it's Hunter
Biden who named the named him this not
me and if you're looking at me you get
to say it if you're looking for some
very interesting conversations with a
lot of people along with maybe some
self-defense classes this is a perfect
shirt for you which you could get on the
best politicalshirts.com because you do
that's why I'm here we also have Mary
Morgan pop culture crisis joining us
tonight I'm back by popular demand happy
to be here yes I am from pop culture
crisis if you don't know go subscribe to
us on YouTube I'm happy to be back I
love the fans well all right and I'm
here pressing buttons as always pressing
the buttons let's jump into this first
story from timcast.com Marco Rubio
canvasser reportedly attacked told
Republicans not allowed in the
neighborhood he was he was also
campaigning for DeSantis as well I
believe he was wearing a Rubio hat and
his hand his shirt oh I'm sorry he was
wearing a dissatis hat and a Rubio shirt
the campaign volunteer who was wearing
apparel supportive of the Florida
Senator and the Florida governor
DeSantis reportedly suffered internal
bleeding and will require facial
reconstructive surgery Rubio reported on
Monday hylia mayor Esteban Steve bovo
said the police department has
reportedly made an arrest though did not
provide further details setting a lack
of information the Miami Herald reported
so apparently I mean Rubio's saying it
was four guys now this is where it gets
fun
because Charlie Chris has come out
himself and I can respect this this is
the Democrat running for governor saying
there's no place for violence in
politics Senator Rubio your canvasser is
in our prayers and we look forward to
those responsible being brought to
Justice we have Val damming saying I
have zero tolerance for any violence
against any person for any reason those
responsible for attacking a canvasser
last night should be arrested and
prosecuted the fullest extent of the law
now I absolutely uh can respect those
calling this out
um the Democrats calling this out the
violence but here's here's I just gotta
here we go from the Miami New Times
Rubio supporter attacked while
canvassing is identified has apparent
white supremacist past okay now the
first thing is a bunch of leftists
pointed this out antifa came out and
said he deserved it they were tweeting
this saying that oh it turns out he was
a white supremacist therefore he
deserves it I think he's Cuban and he's
not white so I don't know if white
supremacists makes sense you know you
can call him something else I guess what
if you want to call him fascist so this
guy gets it's mercilessly beaten and the
left immediately finds a justification
for why I can only assume then they're
probably the ones who beat him and this
was their justification but uh the first
thing I'm going to say yeah I don't like
his opinions if that's the case you know
I've seen some screenshots of things he
may have posted they're accusing him of
posting really really awful stuff some
of the worst of the worst does not
justify mercilessly beating someone to
the point where they need surgery and
they're internally bleeding and then I
want to point out if the Democrats want
to play keep playing games like this we
could now say
Governor uh governor candidate Charlie
Crist defended white supremacists today
that's the game they play in the media
so if they want to come out and attack
this guy who was just beaten and try and
make it seem like there's justification
for it then we can point out oh
Democrats are defending white
supremacists right the simple thing is
no violence condemn it all the dude can
say bad things I don't think it's
relevant to why he was brutally beaten
right right now this is the kind of
stuff we have to call for de-escalation
on I just think it's crazy that they
they're always the right is the real
threat to America or democracy or
anything but if we look at these attacks
over and over again it's always
conservatives that are getting run over
by cars or beaten to a bloody pulp or
Rand Paul's getting attacked by his
neighbor it's it's it's not them that
are getting brutalized all the time it's
our side that's getting this all the
time there's a video going viral right
now of well I will point out just for
the sake of I can hear all the leftists
screaming Charlottesville when you know
James Fields I think he ran I have my
own theory on that but that's fine and
like if you actually watch the footage
but but I mean you know there's there's
a lot to say and does tend to be the one
and BLM and these left extremists going
around causing all the violence and
there's a video right now that that I
retweeted where it's like a guy and his
girlfriend I'm assuming they're walking
and antifa's beating them and then even
an anti-thematic grabs the woman and
she's screaming and I'm like that's an
important thing to highlight for people
is that the antifa people will put red
crosses on their arms
for two reasons
it's a disguise so they can go and beat
people and go I'm just a medic and then
when the pl and then and then also is
propaganda when the police arrest them
then they post horse say the police are
arresting Medics why are they doing it
and it's because they're psychotic
extremist terrorists who are beating
people
I'm looking at the the the article that
you mentioned here I'm trying to find
out the exact sources of what they're
using here but they're also reporting
that the police report is not mentioning
that there was a political dispute nor
does it look or indicate that there was
a specific targeting of this specific
individual so so what's really going on
here are they just trying to justify it
was there any reason is there someone
really going through Twitter finding
someone on the street that's a niche
person saying hey you did this in a
couple years ago I highly doubt that uh
exactly no one's saying that I I know I
know what they're saying is this guy was
canvassing some people saw his shirt in
his hat beat him up and then when the
news broke from Rubio that this guy was
was brutally beaten and told you're not
supposed to be here antifa immediately
rushed out to dig up the guy's past now
here's the other issue I don't know
that's even true because the photos they
posted do not look like this guy unless
he dropped 50 pounds yeah he looks like
a Spanish guy too which doesn't really
add up to a good you know white
supremacist there in the story that they
have there so so again a lot of the
things don't make sense here we don't
know exactly what happened we weren't
there there's not there's no video of
the incident but we have to understand
that our society is becoming more
violent when we look at crimes
especially in major cities there is an
epidemic happening here and whether it's
because of the destruction of our mental
health or just our political class
becoming more hyperbolic by the day it
was just a few weeks ago where Biden
stood behind a huge Podium with the red
lights behind him declaring that that
Maga people are the true danger to this
country and when you have such
sensationalistic hyperbolic language
you're going to have people taking
action on that language which is pretty
dangerous for everyone involved in the
political sphere another interesting
point though to bring up is that they
can always dig into the past of
Republicans too but like it didn't
matter about George George Floyd's past
right like he did he can hold guns to
pregnant women and that's fine any point
that gun like at her belly yeah I read I
don't know is that what he did yeah
and robbed her I I read that he pointed
the gun at her belly and said do you
want your baby to live or die right
right he's fine we can we can I've also
realized that story was completely
fabricated so I don't know what to think
and it's really irrelevant we know that
he had a criminal record that's we know
that he was like drugs when he died we
don't even know what they're saying
about this guy is true I didn't read any
of like the tweets that it says but even
if it were it didn't seem to matter for
their people with their Shady pasts
right and so it doesn't justify violence
it under any destruction yeah it's
always something funny you know I went
to this Market the other day and it was
really really great it was in um Potomac
Virginia I think it's is the name of the
city it's beautiful place wow everyone
there is very wealthy The Mall At
Tyson's I could not believe it was like
being in the capital city of The Hunger
Games the bathroom had like a lounge
section in it like like it was weird
like a half moon chair and and there's
like weird like marble lighting wow and
I went to this market and they had a
some Ruth Bader Ginsburg chocolates and
it said uh notorious RBG and you know I
said that is a perfect gift for Luke and
so I bought it and I brought it back to
Luke the reason I bring it up is that
one of the chocolates it said something
like fight for what you believe in with
the red salute on it the Communist Fist
and I just think it's funny like I know
what the red salute is and means and why
what the symbol is supposed to be but
you see it as a mainstream icon and this
one I I know the left is gonna love this
one they're gonna start vomiting on
themselves screaming when I see the red
salute it may as well be a swastika
right there were two extremist
ideologies in Europe the turn of the
19th century they believed almost the
same things in terms of authoritarianism
they just differed on cultural things
the Communists wanted to purge the
culture the Nazis wanted to reinforce
traditional culture but they both loved
the symbol of the week coming together
to form the strong with the fascists
they had the fascists the bundle of
sticks with the with the blade in it
strapped together because each
individual's trick is weak but together
makes a weapon and the red salute is the
outward facing fist where each
individual finger is weak but together
it's strong that's why they're showing
you the fingers when they do it so when
I go into a store and it's a bunch of
like regular old people being like we're
normal people who don't like extremism
here's our hate symbol you know here's
here's here's a here's a chocolate with
a symbol of of a hundred million dead
and it's normal to people it's
completely normal yeah I was like uh
thank you Tim for the genocide of my
people on chocolate since of course you
know I'm polish I was born and raised in
Poland and that represents you know a
lot of you know just horrible things
that that happened to my people uh the
the all the innocent people that were of
course tortured that were murdered
because they didn't believe in the right
political ideas then of course the
Communists wanted you to believe in and
I think there's a reason why there's so
much genocide and so much communism that
always coalesces together throughout
human history and that's something that
is not really taught in in history class
or in public schools but but there's a
big correlation there and it's not an
accident but the point that you're
making to where it's like all these rich
people and whatever I think we should
just James cloak he was doing a like
what is fascism or is America fascist
type of video and there's all these like
rich people on the beach and and he's
pushing them against like about what is
fascism they have no idea what it even
means they can't Define it right so
they're going around calling like all
Americans or at least half the
population fascists they they don't even
know what it means well here's a funny
thing I watched this YouTube video so I
went to Gettysburg this weekend too and
then you know it's it's a it's like an
hour and 40 minutes or whatever from
your hour and a half and then uh started
watching a documentary series like four
hours long and then in between that
YouTube recommended this what would
happen a video from a YouTuber I forgot
his name so I apologize for this guy but
it was like who would win a Civil War
and it was a really great video he got a
lot of things wrong oh you're talking
about what if all history yeah that guy
that guy red yard he's been he's
mastering the show a couple times here
people have been asking oh okay I
watched his videos really really
interesting thing and uh I forgot
exactly what I was trying to say about
it what were you what were you just
mentioning Gettysburg and civil war
Civil War no no what were you saying
about the rich people not knowing what
like what fascism is and oh right right
right I'm sorry sorry the point he made
is that uh prior to the past 50 years
every political faction was
authoritarian right the the idea that
there is an authoritarian left is new
that the idea there's a Libertarian left
is extremely new and so he he was making
this point where he's like if you were
to take all the political factions from
like the previous conflicts throughout
the past hundred years and bring them to
today they would all be authoritarian
right like even the Communists were very
pro-masculinity and like working class
they just wanted to purge the traditions
and the fascists wanted to preserve the
Traditions right but they were all like
like lunatic homicidal maniacs and the
funny thing I think about it is it's
just like really easy to point out as
like we know the Nazis were some of the
worst in in in in in in our history like
just the horrifying things they did and
the Communists did what 10 12-fold more
substantially more than that right right
yeah oh yeah like 50 times yep the
Communists all together had like 50
times more murder and genocide right but
it's always it's always an answer but
you can buy the red salute in your local
Town Market on a chocolate supporting
your Supreme Court your favorite Supreme
Court Justice did Obama have like a a
Christmas ball with MAO on it in the
White House
I'm not sure about that I don't know we
got to look that way look that up I'm
just saying I feel like I feel like that
was a thing and that was a long time I
remember when I pointed out some some
leftists did the thread salute I mean
they all do it they walk around they
raise the fist they don't understand
that the raising the fist is literally I
I think it was like Ethan Klein or
somebody it was like Tim's criticizing
the universal symbol of resistance and
I'm like that's not what it is like yo
read a history book bro
it's the red salute the Chinese
Communist party when you're when you're
joining it you have to give the red
salute while you recite the pledge to
the Chinese Communist party it's like
imagine if imagine imagine if you you
could like buy a chocolate with a Roman
salute on it it's just it's just Bonkers
that that's acceptable in this country
we're a country of like Freedom loving
libertarian individualist types that's
what the country has founded on yet
authoritarian murderous genocidal
communism has their symbols everywhere
and uh I think you're right Fox News has
an article from 2015 that's titled White
House Christmas decor featuring Mao
zetang comes Under Fire and it talks
about how how Mao Zedong was hanging out
with a drag queen in the in the
depiction there
um it's again an old article but yeah it
was like a really long time ago but
that's okay in the in the white house
it's kind of crazy to see so many
genociders just uh publicly loved and
adored especially Che Guevara when you
look at his history especially the way
he treated people in the lgbtq TQ
Community especially how he treated
people of color uh the history on that
when you look at it is very eye-opening
to say the least what do we think of the
Trudeau mention of his love of Communism
no like the comparison that wants to
space is his father like it's like this
I mean the pictures are funny the
pictures are funny yeah I mean and
that's like there's weird history that
aligns this you know like I like my
conspiracy didn't this mother meet I
think that's what it was yeah like
numerous times I I think it's funny
because like I was reading a Snopes
thing and it's like Trudeau's mother did
beat with Castro and it was around the
time like it was like in a similar time
frame to when he may have been you know
born but I think they're saying it was a
couple years before anyway they they
look quite a bit alike
yeah he doesn't look like his father so
it doesn't look like he doesn't that's
for sure yeah no he's clearly fond of
the ideology so maybe Fidel Castro was a
Milkman in Canada yeah you know maybe
he's
he's trying to grab onto his like his
father's Legacy I don't know it's the
funniest things about these things where
it's like well it is true that Trudeau
does look like him and he doesn't look
like his father and his mother did meet
Castro and did travel down there
it's debunked it's it's not and you're
like well what do you mean like do you
have any evidence like you're you're
giving like there's a thing snopes is
giving us reason to believe it's
actually true not not necessarily sub to
these other a bunch of fact checks it's
like all these points you're making
about you know coincidence and
happenstance our evidence
in the positive and then you just come
out right and say but it doesn't
actually make sense therefore it's
debunked we see that so often with fact
checks in the media
well yeah they just they just they just
pick and choose whatever they want to of
course work for their larger agenda I
did hear that the years don't add up and
that the year that the photos that are
circulating uh don't add up to when he
was born there's other people arguing it
was IVF yeah I don't know how advanced
was that at the time I don't know if
they had that during that specific time
special but there's other people
packaged on dry ice delivered to the
Trudeau household yeah
it doesn't match up for that time that
she met him like there's plenty of
people that still see people without
anybody knowing yeah the other people
are arguing that there was specific
meetings that happened between them a
whirlwind around not documented or I
mean internet of course Fidel I can't do
this my husband will find out this needs
to be made into a soap opera I liked it
yeah I'm just gonna keep trying to
believe that it's true The General
elissimo
no my son it's not my son
all right let's talk about Ted Cruz here
we go from CNN protesters interrupt Ted
Cruz's interview on The View
do you guys see this Ted Cruz is on The
View and it was disrupted by protesters
and it was really funny that people were
saying that it was the cat with the
salad meme because the The View women
like Whoopi Goldberg was screaming at
the audience to like stop yelling and
Ted Cruz was just laughing it's like
having a good time so so you have these
climate change protesters appearing on
The View
they're screaming while Ted Cruz is
talking
and they're they're they're protesting
oil or whatever I don't know what group
they're with cover climate now they
yelled
here's the best part we're 15 days away
from the midterm elections early voting
is already happening and the number one
issue right now in people's minds for
the most part is the economy and gas
prices so when you have a republican at
on The View in front of all these people
and you're screaming no more gas no more
fossil fuels Ted Cruz many should have
been like well I assure you if you've
got Republican will make sure there will
be more of it and then the prices will
come down but think like these activists
I look my conspiracy theory on this one
is that they're being they're being
hired by Republicans
oh I don't know about that including the
soup can girls soup can girls uh
non-binary modules well sweet potatoes
apparently it's an heiress to the Getty
oil Fortune who's been providing some
funding to them and and so I'm saying
I'm not saying it's true I'm saying it's
conspiracy theory why right before the
midterms are anti-oil activists acting a
fool making the left look really really
bad and when gas prices are freaking
people out you know what I mean it's
just I'm not literally saying the
Republicans are paying them I'm saying
they may as well be all Republicans
should be clapping and cheering for this
to be fair we don't like the Republicans
never fight like right anyway and they
don't fight dirty like that that's
probably been one of our biggest
weaknesses so I I couldn't give them
that much credit for thinking that far
ahead they're literally screaming no
more oil like what are you going to be
using that and my favorite calling for
mass murder yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely they don't understand the
larger consequences if we get rid of
people we do understand the larger
consequences and they just don't care or
maybe no maybe they just want to get rid
of people they're consequentialists they
care
like they they care about the Earth and
not the people you know what I mean like
do I care about the the the the the
centipede that I step on as it's like
you're running towards me I'm like oh is
that if you it's like I care to get rid
of it you know what I mean like do you
care about the Wasps you spray you care
in the sense that they they have alerted
you to their presence you don't like
them and now you're doing away with them
you know what you're saying I think that
we can have the same Comforts and
luxuries that we have now without fossil
fuels don't they they want to survive
what I'm saying is they think we can
have the same comfort as we do now
without fossil fuels if tons of people
die you see that you see what I'm saying
you know like when I see a wasp's nest
on my porch I care that is not a good
thing and so I spray them and the wasps
die so they care but not in the way
you'd think a human is supposed to care
about another human yeah my favorite
thing is seeing all the garbage left
after a lot of these climate change
rallies my second favorite thing was
recently seeing a video of these people
gluing their hands uh to the street and
then one of the ladies doing that glued
her hand and took toxic super glue and
just threw it down the drain right
afterwards with a sign that says we need
to protect the environment I mean these
people could be making legitimate
actions there are legitimate things that
we could do to start cleaning things up
especially in our environment especially
when it comes to holding multinational
corporations accountable especially when
it comes to holding China accountable
but they're not doing any of that their
their end goal is to essentially punish
everyone for for not paying enough taxes
to the government which is such an MK
Ultra mind control belief that is just
mind-boggling being able to sit here
saying these people think if you give
the government more money the weather is
going to be gooder that makes no sense
at all the funny thing is is that like
this is this is a picture there's a
bunch look you Google search garbage at
climate rally and there's just like
thousands of photos absolutely super
glue like just them purchasing super
glue you're supporting the petroleum
industry like how many like they don't
realize how maybe they shoplifted it the
um probably but then I mean throwing it
down the sewer I mean come on that's
just they're also putting their money
where their mouth is by not uh bathing
that's true and not having kids so true
or aborting them so it's like the end
result of leftism is it just won't exist
in 50 years I'm okay with that
kind of like I'm okay with people like
you know
I'm not okay with that no no no that's
terrible no but what I'm uh you know you
want you want you want to tell people
that they can have uh abortions and they
can sterilize their kids no I don't want
anybody to have abortions I think that's
murder but I do think that if there's
like a bunch of people like running
rough shot in North Philly and cops are
getting killed all the time that fine
let them go shoot each other well I mean
I suppose as an issue of defund the
police that's what they've been arguing
for so it sounds like you're just saying
you're you're in favor of uh no I'm
saying fund the police fund it actually
not there I mean yeah I wonder where
they're not being crazy and that they
don't support you fund the police so put
extra cops there I'm saying this like
look if if the end result of
let me put it this way
the left comes out and says women have a
right to choose to get an abortion okay
they say uh we're just watching the Ron
DeSantis Charlie Christopher and uh
Ron asks Charlie Chris about child sex
changes and Chris keeps bringing up
abortion he doesn't answer the question
he says abortion abortion a woman's
choice and it's like okay dude
if a group of people are burning the
country to the ground running through
the streets smashing Windows burning
everybody then they come out and it's
their political position they should be
able to abort their children and
sterilize them
I don't understand I I mean I do
understand why conservatives are mad
about it but it's also just kind of a
funny thing where it's like the people
who you think are evil and destroying
everything are also like ending their
genetic line and so it's just like
look I've tweeted this and I will say it
again one of the most shocking things to
me is that you can question fauci and
get banned from every platform you can
question the CDC and get banned from
every platform you can have a public you
could be a doctor who contributed to the
invention of mRNA and they ban you but
if you come out on Twitter
several times and say consider spaying
and neutering your children to save the
planet nobody cares not a single hit
piece no criticism no jokes no mockery
you can say please please abort your
kids there's too many people already not
not a single thing they it just it's
it's shocking me that
I just feel like that should be like
cancel culture worthy to come out and be
like you should abort your kids and
sterilize them they should be like you
you stop but no no they cheer for it and
they're the ones who pretend to be the
champions of the poor when they think it
would be better to be dead than poor
Stacy Abram said abort poor people they
literally say that I was doing I was
doing a one-on-one video and we I was
debating some guy on the street in front
of like the Supreme Court and he I said
your argument there is that
um it's better it's better to be dead
than before and he goes yes that's
exactly what I'm saying I was like like
I didn't even know what to say I just
looked at him like you can't be serious
like what's the end result if they they
all started to sterilizing their kids
and getting abortions
I mean in 50 years they're gone kill
enough people that there won't be poor
people no no just just liberals no right
he's talking about like what I'm saying
is these people it is two this is the
crazy thing it is politically correct
to say
that the left should be allowed to abort
their children and sterilize their
children
how was that that sounds like
nightmarishly genocidal but for some
reason it is a political position held
by democrats
it's trendy according to the agenda and
narrative that they're trying to push on
everybody and uh yeah I mean you could I
mean according to who you talk to Mary
you could you could take out a lot of
poor people especially if you're talking
to individuals like you know Bill Gates
and all these other people who are
pushing this larger agenda against
everyone else specifically he wants to
take them out in Africa not in the west
but in in India too he's doing a lot of
projects there as well it's not
genocidal because they've dehumanized
that right like they say it's a club of
cells or it's not it's not legitimate
but their own kids I know I'm not saying
it's right no I mean like sterilizing
their kids too I didn't hear that well
yeah they're giving they're they're
they're they're giving puberty blockers
oh well then other drugs which are
something completely different like
that's like Munchausen Syndrome that is
what mothers are doing
right sure and for whatever is a bunch
of different reasons for abortions the
point is both result in the left erasing
themselves from from yeah so why should
we complain well they're they're so look
because children are the battleground of
this whole world school choice what do
you want to call it then school choice
is the battlefield so if if the argument
right now is it is politically correct
to to allow people to abort their kids
and sterilize their kids and that is
what YouTube says is the right thing to
say conservatives don't do it liberals
do do it
then okay well all right there you go
you get what you wanted in 50 years
there's no leftists but there's some
intrinsic morality that's there like you
can't go to the Pearly Gates of Heaven
and look at God and say Hey you know I
didn't do anything to stop it because it
would erase all leftists and I was happy
about that like you're trying to live
with your own conscience I think that's
where the Republicans I I understand
everything comes in with that and I
understand conservatives are desperately
trying to save even the people they
really don't like it's it's it's a
fascinating phenomenon my point is just
that and they're happy it is they're
happy to kill us like let's not I mean
they're running look at the guy in in
Florida mercilesley beaten look at uh
Aaron Danielson but but no my point is
is not uh uh to say that Republicans
should you know issue morality and
ethics and and let horrible things
happen to kids it's that the machine
itself is destroying itself The
Establishment is destroying itself with
its own policies and the end result is
either going to be an Islamic world or
just a conservative religious uh um
abrahamic world of some degree I was
saying that earlier this morning because
all of these factions are all of a
sudden like attacking themselves like
the feminists are getting mad at this
LGBT trans kid agenda or women taking
over sports but the funnier the funnier
one is the Muslim Community they've been
more outspoken especially about the like
transitioning and the stuff and LGBT
agenda being in their their schools all
of a sudden things that they wouldn't
report on especially in the UK about all
the grooming gangs and stuff all of a
sudden there's a groom and gang crisis
and and it's I really think it's because
they've been speaking out more about
about the trans agenda and the LGBT
stuff and the schools because they won't
have that they are totally incompatible
and it also then it breaks down these
like uh Coalition building that the left
is trying to do
I I to me I think it's important to
fight for everyone even the deranged
lunatics and the leftists I think
everyone's important we are all a part
of humanity and that's kind of my like
hippy-dippy kind of world view the way I
see it but but also in a larger
perspective I think we have to
understand we're also facing a major
population crisis Elon musk's likes
likes to talk about this a lot uh it's
happening very severely in China right
now but in the United States and
particularly in Europe we're seeing the
decline of the current civilization of
the current population there to drastic
levels where soon there's not going to
be enough people to repopulate and with
that comes major uh crises towards our
entire infrastructure towards our our
entire economic system towards our
entire way of life so just just on that
own population crisis we need to fight
like hell so there are more lives in the
future to make sure that there's not as
much chaos let me pull up this story
from the Independent Biden slams
Republican attempts to ban gender
affirming Health Care in interview with
transgender Tick-Tock star maybe you
guys saw this one the president's
conversation comes the Republicans
continue to pass numerous
anti-transgender pieces of legislation
Biden met with Dylan Mulvaney my
personal opinion is that Dylan Mulvaney
is intentionally trying to insult and
mock trans people and women and that is
is not uh
behaving seriously but uh control that's
what you think I think Bill Mulvaney is
absolutely trolling absolutely I think
that I think that he has
um like Arrested Development from his
like his childhood years and that that's
how he pictures women and yeah he's
going out I got one point for you
wearing high heels in the woods
those
uh consumerist objects really
um yeah if it's what you think uh if
it's Arrested Development and sort of a
child's view of I think all of it is
arrested
I think I I feel like that's naive Dylan
has that viral video saying these are my
hiking heels that is a phrase that
doesn't exist Barbie pouch what's the
other thing there's a bunch of insulting
words that Dylan uses to mock women in
their in their in their Tick Tock videos
but that's how a lot of these these
transgender people are anyway like their
character is that mutually exclusive
with being genuinely dysphoric so if you
take a look at I'll use two examples
that I've used before and that's Contra
points and Blair white they are both
prominent political trans people and
they do not behave that way they behave
like they and neither does Contra they
are both right uh you can disagree with
either of their politics and they both
create well-made YouTube videos
discussing their points because just
just because someone is trans does not
mean they're going to be inherently one
way or the other and and Blair brings up
the uh uh but I don't think Blair has
Arrested Development either I mean like
that's why I'm arguing when when Dylan
Mulvaney makes a video wearing heels in
the woods going
that's that's a come on you think that's
not trolling like if someone put on
blackface and started running around
screaming Fried Chicken we'd be like
that dude is trying to insult black
people not that they have Arrested
Development they think they're black I
think that he's exploiting it and using
it to a disadvantage but I think he is
definitely mentally ill and and
like because he was like a gay guy in
theater right and he was on Broadway or
something like that I got like a little
crazy and I was bored and I watched a
lot of his videos like over and over
again uh a couple days ago but like I
really think they have that look that
like SSRI mentally ill look and why go
by Dylan after a transition bill is a
girl name no no look don't look this is
the game right here
if you look
when you look at Dylan Mulvaney what do
I see I see someone who has created a
caricature which creates a weapon for
people to attack trans people because
I'll mention it again Blair white and
Contra points left and right extremely
prominent and normal behaviors granted
you can disagree with the idea of being
transphoria and say it's in the DSM-5
therefore you know it's considered a
mental disorder according to DSM-5 what
about him like really going through the
process getting laser hair removal on
his face and actually doing the physical
steps like if it I would think that he
would be more of a troll if he didn't
commit to it physically if that's a
troll that's psychotic obviously he's
definitely psychotic and if it's a
mocking caricature like you say like
blackface I think the reason that it
would be more effective and Powerful as
a way to mock women
um compared to Black Faces that like
your gender is a lot more uh crucial to
who you are like who you are as a person
than your race I think your race is just
uh surface level thing about you but
your gender is way more uh core to who
you are and how you relate to people but
more egregious than that is that the
White House is entertaining it like it's
something serious to be talked about
like there are so many other things
going on but sure sure here's an easy
question though so like regardless of
who's right on whether you know Blair
said Dylan is not trolling and I okay
but I look at this why didn't the White
House invite Contra points Contra points
has million million plus subscribers
getting millions of views on these these
hour-long essays that are extremely
prominent on the left with that that
that are calm well and well put together
videos again you can disagree with it
but contact for more left or right I
know okay because I I know players right
so right that's why I bring up these two
specific examples because they're very
prominent uh you know a contra has like
a million and a half subscribers gets
millions of views Joe Biden could have
been like here's a person I can bring
here to talk about these issues that is
calm rational and and politically
prominent Dylan Mulvaney is not
politically prominent and and if you're
trying to advocate for Trans rights the
last person any anyone would bring is
going to be Dylan Mulvaney here's the
thing though like their comms team like
everybody knows that when you're working
in political comms you insert yourself
into the news cycle and Dylan has been
in the news cycle where Contra has I've
never heard of it but I've definitely
heard of it might be Dylan before before
the White House it might be conscious
internet footprint if you will that also
substantially larger controversial but
it's the internet footprint that they
don't want because that's something that
you have to answer for like timing and
it's hyper-conscious old old videos like
those were kind of Politically Incorrect
I think there's something to answer for
there you try to insert yourself into
the news cycle you hit on something
that's big he just had a couple videos
that went viral and they're trying to
capitalize on it that's that's right
shallow is easier but but hey guys the
memes are awesome the memes are
incredible when it comes to this entire
topic especially when they had another
influence over take over the
communications at the White House and
they were just tick-tocking the whole
time around uh the nails yeah today just
moments ago I also tweeted uh the
American people looking all disheveled
uh saying please I can't afford food or
gas and then Danny DeVito coming off and
saying best I could do is this
transgender here that we're gonna be
talking about and and as you mentioned
Tim you're absolutely right this is not
an issue that of course brings America
together this is an issue that divides
America the administration right now has
many problems our society has many
problems that we're facing right now and
this is this is what we're talking about
this is what they're pushing forward as
their agenda to me this is the perfect
way to distract people to divide and
conquer them to have no fighting amongst
themselves as Society literally crumbles
all around so so let's Advance
conversation to the next point in the
article Joe Biden coming out and saying
States should not be allowed to ban sex
changes for children and to me I'm
wondering why what it what is what do
the Democrat Bill Maher made this point
when they were talking about it was I
think it was in 2020 I was in 2018
Democrats were advocating for
transgender rights and prisons and Bill
Maher said I get it we want to protect
civil rights but this is like 300 people
why are they putting it front and center
now you could argue of course hey man
marginalized the most marginalized
voices probably need the most help
because no one pays attention to them
for exactly what Bill Maher is saying no
one's paying attention to this small
group of people therefore someone needs
to
but when Joe Biden comes out choosing an
extremely extremely divisive issue and
one that is extremely unpopular I have
to wonder
why who whose vote is he trying to
secure by coming out and saying children
should get sex changes
I don't know whose vote he's trying to
secure but I will say that you know this
all it all goes back to the um
the Civil Right the Civil Rights era
legislation and so no matter what these
like small minorities do as long as they
couch it in civil rights language
they're never going to get beat no
matter what the vote says because it's
like enshrined and quote the
Constitution so they can say whatever
they want like it the voting population
won't matter it may like slow it or or
you know if if we object to it
temporarily but it's enshrined in law
that like if you count anything in you
know civil rights terminology that it's
going to stay like that so I mean I
guess he's just trying to be on quote
the eventual right side of History
because that's what's going to happen
given what we did in this in what 64. I
think one thing the Democrats do and all
politicians is try is compartmentalize
information and they don't know how to
do it right now and that's the problem
the example being Hillary Clinton when
she was is 2015 I think she went to
where was it Arkansas or Alabama the hot
sauce no she put on Southern drawl oh
yeah she talked a little like this and
it's like Hillary you were in New York
for the longest this time on TV we know
you don't talk like that but back in the
old days you could get away with that
imagine what would have must have been
like campaigning before radio you'd show
up to Boston and you'd put on a Boston
accent people like hey he sounds just
like me and then you go to New York and
you say both instead of both and all of
a sudden people think you sound like
them then you go down the South and you
talk like this and everyone's like but
no one could know how you really talks
you can't write down you know if someone
was at an accent or something right
that's true then we get radio then we
get TV then we get the internet even
with TV
local news is not going to play the
video of Hillary Clinton in you know New
York's not going to play the Alabama
footage they're going to play the New
York footage now we have the internet
also there's a viral video of Hillary
Clinton putting on a fake accent all of
a sudden there's a even AOC just said
I'm just going to say yeah she's so
weird people said that she was imitating
that Meme where that little kid is like
listen Linda listen I think that they
were that she was doing that but she
just tried it's not it's not the accent
it's not that one there was another
event she went to a couple it was like a
year or two ago where she had a really
heavy Latina accent even though
everyone's like we've you went to where
did you go to school like Boston
University or something
like you don't talk like that that's
crazy my favorite thing about that whole
clip was like she's like oh classy
classy like that's what they say and
she's sitting there like spread eagle
like in the middle on the stage like and
she's like dancing classy and her legs
are like
spread open out on the floor for
everyone I'm like oh you're so good
she's so gross I think when they when
Joe Biden has someone like Dylan
Mulvaney at the White House what they're
probably looking at is
this is a person who has all of these
gen Z followers so whatever we say here
doesn't apply outside this bubble right
like they still live in this world where
they think meeting with this influential
person won't Ripple outwards go back 50
years meet with a civil rights leader
and do an interview talking about how
you're gonna defend that defend their
work you're hoping that civil rights
leader will go out to all of their all
of their followers and say Here's what
they told me but is someone who's not a
fan of that person gonna listen to what
they have to say no
what Biden is hoping for is
a hundred people here
what I've just said today and vote for
me and maybe only 10 people hear it
outside of this bubble and get mad at me
for it compartmentalizing the
information thinking you can say
whatever you want because it won't reach
the outer the larger public so I think
there's
sections that are interested in this
trans agenda thing right you have big
Pharma that's going to make tons of
money on it but not just with the drugs
themselves but with like even if you're
confusing children years and years of
therapy like that all costs money right
so big Pharma has an interest in
propping up this stuff right the left
does because they think it's like the
sympathy we're the good guys vote and
then you also have like the creeps that
took advantage of like the regular LGBT
stuff and say hey if we couch it in
these same terms then you know we can
have pedophilia whatever so you have all
these interests that while are not the
same because you know how everybody on
the right like the left says oh you're
talking about they like who's the they
where's the big conspiracy theories it's
not like that they're all in like
there's one guy like pulling the strings
and of course there might be a couple
that are really influential but they all
have competing interests like big Pharma
definitely has an interest in pushing
this
um along with you know well you have a
company that makes money yeah well they
they get patients that are hooked for
the rest of their lives you get them in
early especially the young children
you're going to have someone that's
going to be buying your product every
single month because they need to in
order to live and then remember they use
this and they dump money into his
campaign remember the report that said
something like pharmaceutical or Wall
Street said that cures are probably Bad
Business yep it was a Goldman Sachs
assessment saying maybe we shouldn't
cure people because that will hurt our
profit motive this is the kind of
satanic megalom how do you say that word
megalomaniacal thinking of of these
lunatics who are essentially truly
calling the shots have the big big
corporate lobbyist and when you look at
Dylan Mulvaney like how do you explain
him again testing tampons but then the
next day trying to normalize women
having bulges this is just that's why
I'm saying this is a control it's a
troll it's a desperate need for clout
that's what it is I just looked at Dylan
Mulvaney's Instagram story and saw a
picture captioned peeing at the White
House
I'm telling you this person like that's
just somebody who is desperate for clout
I wouldn't be surprised if in a year
Dylan Mulvaney comes out and says you
are all so dumb because all this is is
mocking women and mocking trans people
now we have to ask ourselves why is this
happening I mean according according to
a tafalgar poor 80 pull uh 80 of
Americans don't support gender treatment
for children so why are they doing this
is it someone at the White House saying
hey Dylan movini's getting all these
views maybe if you get them to the White
House we'll we'll get him to support our
cause and get and tell everyone to vote
for us but people don't understand maybe
people are just watching because it's a
car crash all right I got a conspiracy
theory for you China wants Trump to win
Saudi Arabia wants Trump to win
Tick-Tock is controlled by the CCP and
they are advancing ideologies that are
sabotaging the Democrats because
when Trump is president now a lot of
people might think red top of their head
no no Trump was hard on China that was
bad for China was it Donald Trump goes
America first brings manufacturing back
to the United States in the short term
bad for China in the long term Donald
Trump doesn't want to go to war doesn't
care about the Belton Road initiative
doesn't care about Africa and South
America Donald Trump cares about America
America First in the long run that's
actually really good for China you can
make the argument so Tick Tock comes out
promoting these ideologies the Democrats
Embrace and then Democrats lose Donald
Trump gets in Donald Trump says I don't
understand why we're in NATO I don't
understand why we're in Syria I don't
understand why we're in Afghanistan
China moves in Afghanistan China moves
into other parts of the Middle East
Russia expands their gas Monopoly all
things that may be bad hypothetically
for other parts of the world or who
knows but most most of the people who
support Trump are like why do we care
about these other these things why do we
care about you know what other countries
are doing why why do we care about
intervening in Foreign Wars in Ukraine
so China may be looking at the bigger
picture like hey if Trump is President
America gets out of our way well you
know Biden's giving you know China
Afghanistan on a silver platter
especially when the corporations have
come in when you look at the conflict in
Ukraine you do see China benefiting from
it because it's the United States versus
Russia NATO versus Russia and they're
kind of in the middle watching two
enemies kind of fight each other and
Destroy themselves this is an
opportunity for China to potentially
even take Taiwan so I would just counter
that with those two points when it comes
to theorizing about this Theory
like well I don't know man but let's do
this we got this story from townhall.com
bipartisan CBS focus group stuns host
when panelists agree on almost
everything including woke culture so the
clips actually a bit long what do we
have it's like three and a half minutes
so I'm not I'm not going to play the
full thing for you but it really really
is amazing you've got a republican a
Democrat and an independent and then
they're all just like she asked the
Republican guy and he's like you know I
just don't like this indoctrination of
kids in schools with the weird sexual
stuff that's for adults we shouldn't
have that and then she's like is this
your kids he's like no I'm in Texas but
where I was in Iowa it was bad and she
was okay so you're mad about what's on
the news then it goes to the black woman
in the top left and she's like I agree
with all of that I think it's horrible
I've got a bunch of kids then it goes to
the woman in the bottom right and she's
like yeah I completely agree and and you
know even with the vaccine mandates and
stuff like that in the lockdowns so here
we have one of the most shocking I guess
you know uh panel panels so far in the
midterms we're in the middle of the
midterms because we no longer do
election day now it's election month
right and we're seeing that at least
here
everyone completely agrees so I'm
wondering I I I uh retweeted this person
doesn't I don't know who this person is
on Twitter it's a small account with a
few followers saying come the midterms
Democrats are going to win and the media
is going to ask how could this have
happened and it's because Democrats are
secretly you know hiding and Republicans
are secretly switching to the Democratic
party and there's no evidence for that
claim but I'm like all right you know
I'll I'll retweet that and say let's
let's revisit this one on the ninth and
see what happens I think this is more
evidence along with all the polling
which is insane the 538 forecast now has
basically a coin toss chance that
Republicans win both Chambers and an 81
chance they at least win the house I
feel like looking at this it's not so
much that it's a red wave a red tsunami
it's that Democrats are quitting
Independents are flipping and
Republicans are already 99 I have a good
conspiracy theory for you oh conspiracy
here we go so the Democrats so
traditionally when especially there's a
Democrat president
um in charge we know that it's swings to
the opposite Party come midterms so they
already knew because you know of the the
way the economy is and gas prices and
whatever I think they're chalking it up
letting us win that's why they're
dumping money into like these right-wing
campaigns and stuff right you see the
Veritas video yeah so but my point is
what they're going to do is they're
going to let us have control of the
house and and the Senate so that we can
you know our base no matter what is like
not strategic and they're going to be
like you're not in there you're not
doing enough so then they're going to
start pushing in because we've got these
further right candidates they're going
to start pushing in more far-right
policies that way when it comes time for
them to get the house the Senate and
um
the White House again come 2024 that
it's going to be way easier because
they're going to go point to all our
terrible policies and that's where the
Republicans have to chill about it you
think Joe Biden is going to sign these
policies in the law you think
Republicans are going to the house in
the Senate's gonna pass a bill and
Biden's gonna be like okay I guess you
know I mean depending on what it is it
doesn't matter not just not not just
that but the Democrats have no a-listers
none name a democratic investor no I
can't name one anybody not anybody
that's worth their salt like who's like
in the Republic in the Republican party
you at least have Trump and DeSantis
right and I'm sure you could probably
throw out a couple other b-listers but
well swallow's pretty social he's out
there you know I'm meeting a lot of uh
who's got the X Factor but here's the
thing it doesn't it I don't think it
really matters because if they our base
will push us to start like proposing
radical policies and even if Biden
doesn't do it they'll say you need to
keep him in so that they don't ruin our
country with all these crazy things that
they're trying to implement
they might say look at the Republican
bills that they tried to get through and
Biden blocked if Biden doesn't get
reelected they're getting these things
through you're also you know thinking
that the Republican Republic Republicans
could get something done I I I I've been
very critical of them personally myself
and you know a lot of the times they
come into office and they kind of just
sit on their hands especially when it
comes to the Congress you will have you
will have your newer people in their
proposing legislation if if you have
um we'll just face Arizona I can't Blake
Masters blade Masters definitely going
to want to go in there and like get to
work he's definitely one of those people
but if he gets pushed enough in these
two years by the the right base and
starts promo like putting in policy that
is too far quote right they have
something to run on Big Time in 2024.
the Republicans right now who do they
got they got I mentioned to sandus and
Trump that's easy but Kerry Lake I feel
like Kerry Lake could be president she's
the her the way she speaks the way she's
she's got a commanding presence very
calm and collected very quick-witted do
you think Carrie Lake would want to be
president though you think so like when
we talk what does that look on your face
I just think so I just think it is
I'm saying I I definitely think that I
mean she's poised to be she's articulate
she's great with the media and everybody
loves her like if you were to pull
regular oh she's amazing right now they
say I'd love to see her be president you
know my biases my bias is when we get
like politicians who have come on this
show and it's like pulling teeth
and it's just like the campaign has got
a bunch of stipulations or there's like
weird things and I'm like I ignore it
I'm like bro you can show up sit down or
whatever so I respect every politicians
come on the show because we don't have
like a prerequisite list of like talking
points we sit down I pull up news
stories we talk for a little bit we go
live and then the conversation goes
where it goes
try I try to be respectful I try to make
sure we're being you know my former boss
when he was on here who was it Randy
babbert we were talking about oh right
right yeah yeah that was great you were
great but Carrie Kerry Lake she shows up
an MTG sits down and says sup yeah and
it's like let's just talk and there's no
fear there's no it's just we'll talk
about whatever ask a question that's how
it should be though I I as somebody who
would give advice to comps like comms
advice to
um candidates there's so many times
where they just come in Twitter spaces
and stuff and I'm like stop talking if
they were my my like candidate I'd be
like stop talking I mean you do as a
comps person try to protect them but
it's better when they're just real it's
better I mean the authenticity is really
what matters we were we were watching
the DeSantis Chris debate just before we
started this and uh Charlie Chris pulled
a dirty trick because the campaigns
agreed that there would be no cross
questions between the candidates that
let the moderator handle things and
that's the right way to do it otherwise
you start yelling at each other and then
the audience goes nonsense WWE so Chris
goes Ron are you actually going to be
the governor and and finish a four-year
term why don't you answer right now and
then Ron's like is it my time yet okay
anyway and then the the moderator's like
let me remind the candidates you've
agreed not to ask each other questions
and I thought that uh Chris got him
Charlie Chris got him by asking that and
Ron should have just said yes that's
what you said I said that he should have
said I don't know what the political
landscape is like right now but no
matter what I'll take care of I mean I
think it's more honest I I if it were me
and I was debating and someone was like
do you want you want to be president are
you actually running to be governor and
will you finish four terms
is that a serious question yes I'm
standing here aren't I come outside
waste people's time okay obviously I
want to be the governor obviously I'm
here to finish the job do the job and
finish the term out let's not play
stupid political games okay that's a
better answer than you'll see I'm just
but I'm just so sick of the fake
everything the thing everything when
when Deepwater Horizon is my favorite
example deep water Horizon happens and
there's oil spilling everywhere and then
the the pr guy comes out and says we're
sorry that this happened and blah blah
and I'm like bro everyone knows your
statement is bull crap every single time
a polishing comes out we know everything
coming out of nothing I don't care who
they are just trash coming out that's
why you know when Trump trump came out
today and he was like you know what you
got to do to find the leaker you got to
take the writer the guy who write it
wrote it and you got to lock them up and
then once he finds out he's gonna become
someone's husband then he'll flip and
I'm like that's a horrible psychotic
thing to say wow but Trump just came out
and said it that's so crazy that like I
didn't hear that when was that like
recently there was there's a clip going
around it's going viral War Trump's yeah
he's like I know it's not that released
I I tweeted it it's on my Twitter should
I pull it up are we even allowed to post
videos of trump talking on Twitter
anywhere I mean he's just saying that
you should do you admire that you know
he's just willing to say
crazy things like that I don't like that
he said it I don't like that he holds
the idea the point I'm bringing up is
here it's citizens for ethics the
honesty is refreshing is what you're
saying exactly that this is why people
vote for them they're like well I think
it's bad but but damn if I'd vote for a
liar because when Trump says this
okay so here's a tweet citizens for
ethics says in this horrifying clip
Donald Trump proposes throwing reporters
in jail where they'll be raped until
they give up their sources his crowd
laughed
I think it's terrible thing terrible
thing to believe to say yeah and I think
reporters if if it were me as a reporter
and someone said give me a source I'd be
like nope and if Trump said to me then
you're gonna get locked up and beat and
be raped or whatever or be someone's
boyfriend or husband I'd be like sucks
for you I guess because you ain't
getting anything from me but the point
is
whenever these politicians come out 99.9
of the time you know they're spewing
word diarrhea into your face like a like
a projectile just just spraying you and
you're just like you waste my time good
sir and then Donald Trump comes out and
says this with the Herschel Walker when
like he should have just the easiest way
around the Herschel Walker stuff with
like the abortion and stuff is say I
yeah I did that I'm a different person
it was a couple years ago I'm sorry I've
heard a lot of people in my life and
I've been doing everything I can to make
amends I mean people would have
respected that a thousand times more
than tweeting out like oh that's my son
I love him no matter what like
everybody's rolling their eyes like stop
exactly I was so mad at their camera
campaign staff for that because you know
they're going to the Republicans down
there are going to vote for him instead
of Warnock anyway like let's be fair
let's let's be honest Trump's comments
here definitely bring some interesting
context to the Julian Assange Saga well
it was involved let's let's play this
tweet and we'll we'll set a segment for
it so we can actually
this is what Trump this is what Trump
had to say here so everyone gets the
full context in a tweet from citizens
for ethics they say in this horrifying
clip Donald Trump proposes throwing
reporters in jail where they'll be raped
until they give up their sources his
crowd left here we go you know in this
country oh wait wait I see I always do
that yeah every single time and it's
because we're listening to the debate
earlier but here you go
easily made public you know in this
country they leak all over the place
even on the Supreme Court by the way you
have to find the leaker of the Supreme
we have to find the liquor
you know how you find the link in the
league they'll say oh this is treasonous
what I said so they can't find the
liquor he leaked all about row v Wade
like this person leaked from the Supreme
Court never happened you know how you
find but they don't want to mention this
because they think it's so terrible you
take the writer
because you're never going to find
another going through phone records it's
been a long time you take the writer and
or the publisher of the paper a certain
paper that you know and you say who is
the leaker National Security
and they say we're not going to tell you
they said it's okay you're going to jail
and when this person realizes that he is
going to be
the Bride of another prisoner very
shortly
he will say I'd very much like to uh
tell you exactly who that liquor it was
Bill Jones I swear he's a liquor and we
got him but they don't want to do that
they don't want to do that but that's
the only way you're going to find we
have to find can you imagine they leak
out so I'll just point out first and
foremost that we need prison reform
because the idea that you get locked up
and rape is a threat against you I think
that violates which amendment is that
cruel and unusual punishment yes yes
yeah I don't know the idea that in our
society it is normal and expected and
believed that's the case is like okay
that's that's cruel unusual punishment
well if anything then the leaker should
just be charged with treason and then
you know well it's guilty or not guilty
it would be sedition not just
accordingly so uh uh just just to be
specific sedition they already know who
who the leaker is anyway like let's stop
they know who the leaker is they know
who the Gen 6 bomber is they knew who
all those people are they just don't
want to do anything about it because
it's on their side I mean they have
total information surveillance they have
the NSA that literally watches almost
every little thing you do and they're
playing stupid here that's that's a
point to make here Trump's comments here
are atrocious and again leakers
whistleblowers serious yeah I think it's
fair we all make like f'd up jokes
behind closed doors he just says it in
the open I I think that's a larger point
that I was going to make here as I said
his comments are okay you can but but
his comments are atrocious I I think
what this country has done to leakers
and whistleblowers is immoral but when
you look at his administration it was
filled with leakers and he didn't do
anything when you look at the Obama
Administration he was very heavy-handed
on leakers threw them in jail and used
the Espionage Act against them Trump
didn't even go that far but these
comments are are bombastic these
comments are Are Over The Line yeah
that's why I agree with Mary that
Trump's obviously joking because he did
not go after these people in this way
Obama did Obama arrested journalists
literally and Trump is is only making
gross comments about arresting children
but then we have the you know Julian
Assange that's true Julian Assange is a
leaker and no no he's not a junior he's
a journalist who was helping leakers
release information
um and this is the person that Trump
would take in jail and essentially have
you know what what he said there let's
and you if you look at you know Julian
Assange Donald Trump said that he was a
hero a couple years ago now he acts like
he doesn't know who he is
and the reason that he failed to Pardon
him According to some sources according
to the information that that we've got
was because Julian Assange wouldn't leak
who was the source of the information
when it came to a lot of the Hillary
Clinton emails and because of that
Donald Trump and because of the pushing
by Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump didn't
pardon Julian Assange and decided to do
Kodak Black so I just want to you know
clarify that point Point Barack Obama
the president before Trump locked up
journalists locked up whistleblowers
spied on them spied on a spied on them
Adam Schiff released the private phone
records of John Solomon and Donald Trump
said nasty things
I don't like that Trump said these nasty
things I think it's it's it's a scary
thing to say but you've got all these
leftists that are like he's so evil well
how come these people vote for him and
I'm like bro you voted for Obama Obama
went after that Fox news reporter like
more than once who was that guy do you
remember that guy
um James ryzen was that his name I think
so yeah
so come on we also have uh other stories
that I'll that I'll I'll leave more
Vegas
like the the bark is lighter than the
bite like do you really want he's always
been that way yeah like he doesn't he
doesn't really come down as harshly as
you'd want him to
um a lot of times and I'm not saying
that I agree with what he said because I
don't but it's always been that he has a
pension for hyperbole I feel like it's a
Northeast thing and like the the rest of
the world doesn't seem to like get that
he also doesn't do favors for the people
that you want him to do favors for the
reason that he pardoned those rappers is
essentially that like he is obsessed
with being liked being popular he comes
from the entertainment industry that's
what he's about and it shows man so you
guys going to vote for Trump 2024 yep
yes
you know being a part of a divide and
conquer system not being a part of it I
don't have a system that of course again
it depends who's running first of all uh
who's out there if Dave Smith is out
there if Peto Peter's out there if if
Ron DeSantis is out there it's a big
thing but obviously I've criticized
Donald Trump uh I criticized his
connections to Henry Kissinger John
Bolton I think anyone in power needs to
be held accountable I think he failed in
a lot of his policies he was different
he shuffled things up he definitely
rattled some parts of the establishment
but he definitely coddled another part
of the establishment and I think uh we
could do a lot better and when someone
is ego focused we do better I think so I
think we could absolutely do a lot
better I think I think there's a lot of
potential he had the experience issue he
didn't have the right people surrounding
him I think that you know years in there
will help that the Santa seems like the
better fit because he has the experience
or he did but he has that under his belt
now and I think that he would be a
little more cautious and look back and
see what he he's done wrong and Surround
himself with better people this time and
actually listen Maybe I mean seeing
these comments and and then seeing what
he says about the vaccine seeing how
he's I didn't like the vaccine seeing
him just coddle the big Pharma and and
criticized people who are against it
that right there should highlight
something
um and along with you know just all the
other things he did before it makes you
really wonderful about the vaccine that
was still about Trump and his ego it's
all it's it's not being able to admit
that he might be wrong but he doesn't he
doesn't want to admit hiring people like
Bolton bringing him on I mean I wanted
to have Bill Gates as a science advisor
okay that that's that's a huge red flag
for me and and as soon as you're trying
to get Bill Gates in positions of power
in government to regulate things in your
life you're going to have some problems
so I don't think Rhonda Sanders will run
against Trump he will I don't think he
will either I absolutely think he will
only run if Trump doesn't if there's
like a hole to fill there I would I
would I would probably I would rather
vote for DeSantis but if the issue is
you know if it's between Trump and his
Anderson they're both running then I'd
just be like well it's a coin toss
between the two and if it's Trump and
nobody else it's Trump I'm not I mean
Trump's saying he's going to fire all of
these bureaucrats or try to that's with
a schedule left stuff I mean certainly
not going to be a Democrat what do they
even stand for claiming they want to end
fossil fuels and then begging the Saudis
for oil there's no platform there at the
very least Republicans are like we don't
like the wokeness in the government and
I'm like okay those things are illegal
and they shouldn't be there anyway at
least I can vote for that
no Wars under Trump I have no problem
just for the record I have no problem
criticizing Donald Trump I criticized
him in a video like a long one about the
two thousand dollar stimulus that was
pathetic that he was advocating for that
that was like really bad there's there's
a lot of things that I agree that he
that he did but I think that overall it
was better than any of the Alternatives
I wanted Rand Paul originally people
yeah people are saying unsubscribe from
Luke uncensored that's fine that's okay
and I've been expressing these opinions
from the very beginning I'm seeing the
comments I read all the comments all the
time I'm not here no I'm not here just
just to please people in the comment
section I have my own thoughts and I'm
not here to just go along with the group
think and I think it's important to
challenge certain narratives yes ghost
girl with your little sigh here it's
important to question things it's
important to to question anyone in
Authority especially when there's so
much that you could go back on you could
say and I don't want to be that person
that said oh you could just go back and
criticize everything no no no it's
important to hold people's feet to the
fire including when they do things that
actually hurt people and when the Trump
Administration brought in the two weeks
to slow the spread when they brought in
Dr fauci when they brought in operation
fast uh warp speed that they caused a
lot of irrevocable damage to society to
this country when they started handing
out checks to random individuals that's
a problem right there all right and if
you're not willing to hold your own
party accountable you're not willing to
be the best party uh that there could be
and yes other parties absolute crap but
I don't want to choose between one piece
of dog crap and another piece of horse
crap but that's just me all right but
hold on hold on right now between the
two of you what what Lisa is saying is
Trump made a lot of mistakes I agree
with you but I think he's learned from
those and he's he's expressed that he
has and you're saying he made mistakes
therefore he's irredeemable no uh uh I
don't think he he redeemed himself from
those mistakes If he if he if he comes
forward and says hey guys you know maybe
you know putting fauci in power maybe
doing operation warp speed I thought she
was already there he could have fired
him what he what is Trump saying right
now about the vaccine that's an
important aspect here right that that's
that plays along into a lot of different
things and what he's saying right now I
can't even mention here probably on this
show but but but there there should be a
larger debate about that specific issue
that should be a warning sign to
everyone let me ask you guys do you
think the Republicans if they win every
every branch do you think they will ban
abortion Nationwide
oh I don't think they should
I don't think they should in the next
two years that's do you think they will
in the next four
2024. it's uh November well I don't know
election day is going to fall in
November Donald Trump wins to Gap
presidency the Republicans secure the
hold on uh the house the Senate they got
the Supreme Court six to three Trump
wins the presidency and now they have
the path cleared before them do you
think they ban abortion Nationwide 27-28
possibility yeah after those midterms
yep after those midterms I don't know
though because historically it would be
a Democrat flip so they have to do it
before it's actually more only
historically a Democrat flip when
there's a Democrat president
when you look at the numbers like yeah
it doesn't actually happen as much as if
a republican the swing isn't it the
swing is mostly when the Democrats yeah
when there's it's it's more extreme than
there's a Democrat okay do you think the
Republicans want to ban abortion I I
want to ask you about like political
expediency is it within the Republican
agenda to ban abortion Nationwide
I don't think they will I don't know if
it were in their agenda I think that
more would have happened on that front
I think they like to tout it a lot and
that's like exactly what I have the
problem I have with like the Trad life
like while I believe in everything that
they say it's like the people that are
always espousing it are the worst where
did they come from I don't know I mean I
like what they said yeah women should
stay home I mean I shouldn't be forced
to like you know work whatever not the
point the point is that's another that's
a whole nother day I believe in
everything they're saying but if you
ever look or look at the personal lives
of the people that are actually like
promoting that stuff there like the most
vile ones out of all of them and so it's
kind of like I don't think while the
Republicans sure like to tout it a lot I
think that the majority of them just
like to say the words I uh I mentioned
this a couple times I visited Gettysburg
read a whole bunch of plaques and
actually I mean for people who don't
know the area where we are with Harper's
Ferry with Antietam we ride our bikes to
Antietam battlefield for like coffee
it's really crazy to like you know
growing up in Chicago not seeing this
stuff and everywhere you go there's like
these these these historical plaques
they have explaining what happened there
and there's cannons everywhere and then
I watch this documentary and I thought
to myself uh if the Republicans
abortion is very much the same same on
the same moral level as slavery it's not
necessarily you know I know you can be
there could be arguments on one being
worse than the other I'm not saying that
I'm saying as an issue of moral conflict
I I think that
it is very likely the Republicans do ban
abortion it does cause a dramatic
escalation and I do think that abortion
if we are to follow the historical track
in human rights expansion abortion will
be outright banned it will be abolished
completely and then we will look back on
whatever Civil War happens because of it
assuming it does the same way we look at
slavery that is not an opinion
personally about pro-choice or pro-life
it's an opinion about historical track
track records but do you really think
that like women are the people that care
about the abortions do you think that
there would be a civil war over abortion
I don't like what
is exactly the point people don't know
enough about the Civil War neither do I
when I actually went went to Gettysburg
for the first time and in fact living
out here talked to a lot of people visit
you know met people out here have told
me stories went up to Gettysburg and
then actually read everything and talked
to a few people then I watched this
documentary I was like wow what
percentage of people in the United
States owned slaves at the time of the
Civil War I think it was five percent
so if you came out and said come on
slave owners you think there's gonna be
a fight a civil war over slavery when
only when the Confederacy is is four
million uh white population and only 25
percent own slaves that's only five
percent of the entire country that was
also tied up in males male ego in that
like hey this is like this is our our
state or this is what we believe in
whatever when it comes to abortion it's
a female that's why when robots people
are in the chat disagreeing but when men
care
we're divided by States right now some
states are Banning some states I'm not
sure what I'm saying didn't you notice
that when Roe v Wade was overturned we
had no riots none where were the riots
they just automatically disappeared
right it's supposed to be one of the
hottest issues there and we had zero
riots with people prepared for them
people did everything nope but when
George Floyd gets killed or whatever it
has to men are not going to go out and
fight so that you can so that when I'm
telling you you got it you got to read
more about the Civil War in that case
because I see what you're saying the
idea that the average Southerner went
out and grabbed a gun saying slavery the
government of the Confederacy was trying
to enshrine slavery for sure but the
average Southerner that was fighting was
not a slave owner but it wasn't a
woman's issue they don't care men are
not going to get up and fight over a
woman's issue because abortion is
primarily about women being sexually
available for men but also that's why a
lot of people this is a moral issue of
Human Rights no I agree that it's like
but men are not going to be like driven
to the streets and and like they weren't
they were not riding in the streets when
Roe v Wade was overturned I mean I
didn't even see women riding not like
it's in their nature anyway but they
couldn't get much done if they try
there's not gonna I just don't I from I
saw them dressing up like a handmaid's
tale yeah that's what they do when they
go and challenge I saw them doing that
right taking attention there's no
nothing there was no destruction Sheamus
made this point several times he said
that in U.S history there has never been
a conflict seeking to guarantee human
rights that has has that has gone
towards stripping them away in the long
run right basically as as we've moved
forward as a nation and progressed we've
continually expanded human rights not
rescinded them the argument that it's
women's rights to choose is it's the
same as arguing in my opinion that a
slave owner has a right over someone
else's body granted there's a difference
between an unborn fetus and a you know
human beings who are being on I think
slavery is very very obviously wrong and
I think we came on the right side of
that one historically but the argument
that someone has a right to choose to
terminate someone else's life is is it's
a very very bad thing now for me I fall
in the more libertarian Camp of I also
don't like the idea of the government
coming in and determining someone has to
give their body to somebody else which
makes it an impossible ethical standard
that I'm not going to pretend to have
the answers to because I just I don't
know it's a body inside a body it's two
separate bodies two bodies right and so
you're trying to argue about civil
rights but the way uh Sheamus put it
many other pro-lifers is that the
temporary uh uh displacement of the
woman's uh you know the woman's life for
the permanent life of the baby is the is
the is the proper uh outcome meaning
killing the life of the baby
to to help the woman to save the woman
nine to ten months of suffering is is is
inequivocal inequivocal or you know what
I'm trying to say it doesn't balance out
right they're arguing that it's
unfortunate the woman has to suffer but
the baby gets to live a full life of 70
to 80 years whereas you can kill a baby
with no life just so the woman doesn't
have to go through 10 months or or so
nine months of I say 10 because there's
before and there's afterwards there's
postpartum and there's things like that
so there's going to be this period for a
minute but but anyway look in my
political opinion is not uh and it's
funny that I can say this because like
imagine being in the time of slavery and
being like trying to be a Centrist where
you're like well you know I personally
think it's wrong but I'm not gonna
abolish it I understand the position I'm
in especially historically but just
reading about the Civil War reading
about how no one cared about it like
this is the crazy thing the
abolitionists were extremists they were
a small tiny faction no one cared about
and it was like five percent of the the
country that actually had slaves and so
it was rich white Southern uh southern
slave owners that made up it was about
25 percent of the Southern population
which ultimately because it's a small
population
and uh most people didn't care I was I
was reading I was I was watching a video
talking about the politics the papers
the propaganda and it was like
people in the north didn't care for war
here's a really great example the the
Emancipation Proclamation didn't
actually abolish slavery in like three
states only the states that were in
Rebellion against the the union and so
Lincoln was actually promising like
Maryland and I think Missouri the right
to keep slaves because they weren't
rebelling against the union it's it's
didn't Lincoln also want the
repatriation of former slaves what do
you mean like he wanted African slaves
to be repatriated to their home Liberia
yeah not just Liberia but like no they
there was a thing that they would send a
groups of them back over to Africa and
repatriate anyway are you are you
suggesting though that um a civil war
kicked off by a federal decision on
abortion would
Maybe
be more destructive to the country
because abortion affects more people
than slavery ever did no no no no what
I'm saying is people are saying right
now abortion can't like there's not
gonna be a civil war of abortion like
nobody cares that much it's like okay go
read the history of the Civil War and
see how many people cared about that
issue nobody cared about that yeah there
there were a lot of people Hans
Christian Hague we talked a bit about
him because he was a foreigner who
fought and died for the union
abolitionists were real John Brown was
was real depending on your perspective
on History he was either a hero or he
was a terrorist I mean these are crazy
stories you think about I want you to
Imagine This a guy goes to uh gets a
bunch of his kids and his friends and
family and gets guns and goes to an
abortion clinic walks right after the
doctor and blows his head off that's
John Brown was John Brown a hero because
he was doing that to slave owners he
walked there's there's a story about how
he went to uh he went he wasn't I think
it was in Kansas he didn't care to ask
any questions he didn't care to take
prisoners he just went up and started
killing these people and and he's
considered a hero because slavery was so
wrong what I'm saying is at the time
people didn't in the north didn't care
because the North like it was a
political issue for sure
but people in North were like hey look
first of all segregation lasted until
the 50s so you need to understand that
even the north people were very racist
and were for segregation and didn't you
know didn't care for for doing uh more
lynchings persisted until the 1900s this
idea that the north were like great
Heroes of equality is just not true my
point is not to not look I'd watch a
document in Civil War so here I'm
talking about it no I'm thinking that
what the Republic we we're looking at
States
separate staunchly and abortion Colorado
No Limits Texas bans we're seeing these
states light up in this way and I'm just
like man if the Republicans move in that
direction it's not
I think people underestimate how how
politics works I would say it would it
could be just like slavery was some like
tip of the iceberg or tilt the scales
type of issue it's not going to be like
a driving factor that sets it off there
may be some power dynamics there may be
some other stuff going off that's
exactly right so there's a lot of stuff
that I'm I've so I've been reading about
the Civil War quite a bit then going to
Gettysburg got me to read a lot a bit
more and watch this documentary
and the Confederacy was definitely
trying to enshrine slavery the the vice
president overtly expressed white
supremacy as the as the core as one of
the cores of the Confederacy like
literally expressing his genetic
superiority and a bunch of other stupid
nonsense but for the average person in
the South they weren't fighting a war
because they had slaves they didn't so
what what what they what a lot of people
were telling me is the South knowing
that they needed to boost morale by
creating other issues by by highlighting
other uh eccentricities of the federal
government uh presenting conspiracies
and things like that Robert E Lee didn't
even own slaves and didn't believe in
slavery right so so here's what ends up
happening with the battle at Fort Sumter
it's the fighting that breaks out was
not because the north was like we must
march on the south to end slavery it was
two years after the start Abraham
Lincoln signs the Emancipation
Proclamation which explicitly said only
in rebelling States so even then they
weren't trying to end it so it was the
star it was the core like principle
reason for the conflict and the paranoia
between the South and the north but the
fighting itself was just like tribal
hatred and that was under production
tomb right like there the the whole
reason that the north won was because
they held all the means of production
which is what always scares me
manufacturing yeah manufacturing right
and it's held by the right right now
yeah I thought China is holding them
that's always my thing and I was like
did we not learn anything from the Civil
War who wins the war the people with the
means of production and that goes for
antibiotics that goes for steel
production neon all the things let me
let me tell you some more stuff that
that'll freak you out a little bit a lot
of people say you know Bill Maher he
says if there's another civil war okay
there can't be another civil war because
the Mason-Dixon Line would go through
Nana's Kitchen it's like okay Bill we
get it you're snide but anyway anyway I
think it was
um Robert E Lee or it may have I think
it was a lead and he uh these were these
were Union Generals and the question of
secession was coming up and they said
who do you side with what am I supposed
to do and I think it was Lee who said he
could not Envision raising his arms
against his home state so ultimately he
said I have to go to the South against
Virginia right yeah against Virginia
correct so I want you to imagine
California
and what would happen with the National
Guard if California says outright
any any child can get a sex change any
woman can get an abortion no matter what
and then the National Guard says are we
going to uphold this it's clearly in
violation of federal law I mean
president DeSantis has already banned
this federally and now we're forced to
uphold it it's a question for each and
every one of these National Guardsmen
you live in California your friends are
in California your mom's in California
dad's there your shopkeeper you know the
local Town councilman do you raise your
arms against them we don't have you it's
not against that we don't have the same
loyalty to where we come from anymore at
all that's all been that's all it's not
about the state it's about your friends
and family in that state and whether
you're going to be the one rounding them
up and locking them in camps as
dissenters or going to be the one
defending them
yeah I just when the if if the Union
soldiers were to march on Virginia and
go and occupy those towns would you be
the one point in the gun at at your
friends and family or would you be the
one defending them
I mean how much people have like family
that like there that much I I just don't
think that your families are spread out
as much as you think they are like it's
not it's not going to be like you know
I've got my mom in Pennsylvania and my
brother and I'm in my mom in New Jersey
my brother in Pennsylvania and like I
have to pick it's gonna be like hey you
guys come with me we're going to be on
the right side of History we all have
our political values that are exactly
the same and we're on a team but no
one's no one's thinking that
you being ordered to March into your old
neighborhood and tell everyone to stay
in their houses while you're holding a
rifle and them being like get out of
here we've said no to you I could do
that if it was ideologically aligned so
we had John podesta doing that uh that
war game in 20 2020 where uh I think it
was podesta you had the Democrats and
neocon Republicans basically playing
Dungeons and Dragons for politics and
The Advocate the Democrats advocated in
their scenario for the west coast to
secede from the union if Donald Trump
were to win a second term as president
the federal government then says we are
giving explicit orders to the National
Guard to go out and stop these people
from doing it and then you have to ask
yourself are you going to protect your
family or protect the federal government
that's what Robert E Lee was basically
saying it's not a question of being like
the word Virginia means so much to me
and the word United States does too but
I was born in Virginia so I choose that
word no it's like yo I'm not going to
point a gun at my neighbor bill
yeah get out of here you're not marching
on my my hometown it's not going to
happen you know what's interesting about
this whole thing it's funny because I
feel like if California wanted to secede
we'd allow that but like I always feel
like the left would never let us go like
they would never let the right seat like
that we would say all right you want to
go you want to have California go have
California and they would be like no you
can't go if we if Texas wanted to say
well I'll give you I'll give you the
shout out Luke on this one because you
keep talking about peaceful divorce
right and that's exactly what the South
was saying an amicable split and the
north said we won't let you lead right
like we won't let you leave and I think
that that's akin to the left now and the
right like if the right all said okay
we're tired of your weird policies you
have you know this half in Canada and
we'll have the bottom half they would be
like no you're never leaving and then
once they see that it's great down here
they would come over and invade us
anyway what was that YouTube channel I
mentioned earlier what what if all
history what if all history he basically
said in his video that the right is
almost is basically guaranteed to win in
all aspects military training resources
food production hands down no questions
asked capability in general the the
entirety of Rural America is connected
and the the leftist America is islands
is it's it's where they call the
Democrat archipelago uh something like
that I mean he made the point that it's
you know the the coastal Elite basically
a similar point to that but it's true
all the production be it manufacturing
be it food growth Etc occurs in the
center of the country and then
everything else goes out to the coasts
we still have manufacturing we have a
little bit marginally I don't know yeah
it's it's not that significant a lot of
the stuff is just imported because of
globalization policies instituted by
David Rockefeller uh but but at the end
of the day you know it it's a hard thing
to to really talk about because how do
you how do you fix this larger divide
that's getting farther and farther from
each other how do you fix people that
are becoming more violent against each
other for their political ideas how can
you even have a peaceful divorce how can
you have a divorce maybe that even has a
mutual peace pact or a mutual defense is
that possible but you know it's it's a
hard question to kind of know yourself
it's never been solved I don't think it
can so you know I'm I'm in Gettysburg
and you know what all these people up
there telling me they give tours and
stuff they said well you know the Civil
War was Unfinished Business from The
Revolution from from the war from
independence from the from the colonial
days and I'm like uh-huh and so what
you're basically saying is that all of
these major issues that have been
affecting the country they all they all
connect all the way back it just goes on
forever so you get you get Civil War you
get reconstruction I was reading that
there's not even an official date to the
end of the Civil War because some
Confederate soldiers kept fighting even
though there was the the apatamax
surrender then you had the
Reconstruction then you had this this
Council hearing it was like 1876 I think
where they there was contested election
so they just had a committee meeting of
like okay I guess we'll just decide
you'll be president so we don't go to
Civil War again but then you end up with
the clan Nathan Bedford Forrest who was
who I think he was was he a general in
the Civil War or he was a right he was
an officer a general I believe
then you get the clan then you get civil
rights and you get all that conflict and
now we're still dealing with remnants of
all of that and fighting is coming out
granted a lot of it's washed away almost
everyone universally in this country
opposes racism to a great degree there's
small factions that are still in favor
of it the left seems to be the most in
favor so it's getting weird and murky
yeah I think the best thing we could
strive to do is reduce harm
um any way we can this is why I kind of
advocate for a peaceful divorce or even
just trying to work it out where we
don't have a strong federal government
that keeps imposing its ideas onto
everyone and I think the more we allow
Choice the more we try to get rid of a
centralized big federal government that
could be Republican or Democrat pushing
the ideas onto different states I think
the better off we would be and the less
harm and the less conflict we would have
I totally disagree I feel like that's
not like a reality situation I think
that there's Cycles to every government
there's rise and falls and there's war
and that is a nature and part of being
human is is these cycles of of
government and control and power and
that we are at a point where it's going
to come to a head there's going to be a
fight for whatever is right and then
this cycle we'll start over again and
I'm like let's just get there I'm not
saying you're wrong but I think we
should try to avoid getting there I
think we shouldn't be racing there
because when Americans start fighting
Americans that's really going to be
extremely dangerous and harmful to
everyone and I think we should be doing
our best to reduce harm in that uh in
that YouTube video I keep referencing uh
from what is it what if all history
right yeah whatever history he mentions
Strauss how generational Theory and he
actually expands upon it that it's not
just in the United States but in the
English-speaking world every 80 years of
the conflict and he mentions a couple
more before the American war for
independence and then he also mentions I
think three other books that have this
is really fascinating he goes through a
bunch of different theories that I'll
talk about the past and the ebb and flow
of civilization and Chaos yeah great
videos and they all say in the 2020s
we're going to have chaos and then you
have MIT I believe who came out and said
in the 2020s is it what is it like in
the 80s and then 40 years we're going to
see major chaos and strife in the United
States so they're all predicting it may
maybe they're all wrong and I won't need
to eat the beans in my basement I don't
know if they're all wrong but I will say
that if you look at cycles and trends of
civilization and when they fall it's
always with the
um loosening of sexuality especially
when it comes to women well
civilizations usually have that
correlation as well as the degradation
of society entertainment a lot of it is
just weird awkward doesn't make a lot of
sense and I think we are in that phase
yeah because fourth turning as some
people reference it there's that thought
I was just reading that book what was it
um then
the Age of Enlightenment right uh
entitlement the age of entitlement oh I
keep doing this with the mic okay so the
age of entitlement
um and he says in there like there is
always a battle about of like your
personal need for flexibility and
sexuality versus your the structural
need for survival and constraints on
your sexuality
um and that's like what the story of
Romeo and Juliet was and that there's
always that conflict and when the one of
the individual wins out and that's when
Society really deteriorates because
you're missing that that construction of
the family and and restraint that you
need in order to live in civil society
and so it's it's really women burning
their bras in their 60s it ruined
everything for us but it's not just in
the 60s though because feminism started
way before that I know but it was a big
movement witchcraft in in the 19th
century really
right I mean like women learning math
I mean ultimately we can blame the
printing press for everything oh yeah
for everything that's gone wrong how do
you uh how do you create a society where
people are uh
free as individuals to live in and
choose as they see fit I don't think you
should have less and less government
just have less dependent on government
people dependent on government stay
dependent on government because it hooks
them in the government there is not to
saw is not there to solve any problems
but there to get people who will need
them forever but I'm talking about
culturally you think you're saying you
think women I've made yeah I've
definitely made a further like turn I
guess re I guess within the last like
years years maybe two years or so
further to the right in that there's
another good book that I'll put um
cerebri's book and he he said this great
little like anecdotal thing it's a and
I've kid so I know so you bring two kids
to the sandbox they're like 18 months
old one kid brings a toy they're both
sitting in the sandbox the other kid
steals the toy from the kid and the kid
says hey that's mine you can't have that
starts freaking out right so that gives
you a thing that that's not like taught
in society there's an inherent sense of
justice and right and wrong and morality
but a mom comes in or some you know or a
dad or somebody comes and says yo we
don't live like that we live in Civil
Society in this town so while I think
that you need to
um you know embrace the individual and
give them some flexibility and some
freedom to grow there I do think that
there needs to be some agreed upon very
you know moral structure there and I
think that we've gone past that and
everybody has all these like dark images
about like authoritarianism and things
like that because we've seen it get out
of control but there's also been a lot
of benevolent benevolent dictators
there's also been kings that have wound
up you know accruing sainthood because
they were so good to their people and so
I just think that they're we are so
lacking in immorality that there needs
to be some not everybody is capable of I
mean think look around like look at the
supermarket the people aren't capable of
making their own decisions on what food
to buy I think that there just needs to
be some structure in the society and it
needs to be something we all agree on
and we are far past that's not a right
or left thing I mean Bloomberg said we
should tax the poor because they're too
stupid to make their own decisions he
said well when we tax them we can spend
the money better because they tend to
make mistakes something like that do
they mean the poor do they mean the
middle class
he meant I'm not talking about personal
decisions like that much I I mean more
some more enforced morality some you
know like we used to shame people we
used to you know scoff against divorce
we use it and and people have like
totally exploited all that it used to be
for some some basic reason like some
serious reasons that people get divorced
or leave their family or anything like
that or men would go outside the home or
no no fault no fault divorce was the end
of it right entirely completely 100
marriage no longer exists with no fault
everybody lifts up Reagan right but
Reagan Reagan was awful gun control
horrible yeah yeah horrible guy I mean
I'm just saying that like I think that
there needs to be some bounded morality
and I think that yeah you know it that
sounds scary to a lot of people but I
think that it's the only way out of this
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already but to kindly
smash that like button Smash It uh-oh
it's a civil war inside of the comment
section oh really I love it it's great I
can't really the little thumbs up under
the video player become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you at about 11
p.m they're always fun and they're not
family friendly so uh do all that smash
the like button share the video let's
read epic gamer says some breaking news
Penn State canceled Gavin mcinnis's
event because of a mob of protesters and
black block yelling communist chants
Lord Fisher has a live stream going it's
winding down at this point he was there
with Alex Stein tonight oh he was yeah
so yeah yeah yeah because I somebody
asked if Alex was going to be here so I
asked him I said Alex are you going to
be here with me and he's like you're
gonna be on now I'm going to be in Penn
State where is where's Penn State no
Pennsylvania no I know I know but it's
in Philly no no it's like right here or
something yeah it's like um State
College State College it's like a center
Center of PA or something yeah it's not
it's not close
but it was funny because I was coming
but I think it's relatively close to
here
uh maybe a couple hours no but yeah so I
was like he's there McGinnis is there I
can't believe they shut it down what
jerks anyway
all right I'll watch that when I get
home Bill Hughes says VP Harris falsely
calls her support of the Minnesota
Freedom fund misinformation
that's true I watched this video clip do
you see it they were like you you've
been accused of supporting this she's
like well that's just misinformation and
disinformation because she's a crackpot
who doesn't realize that she actually
has a tweet up doing this okay receipts
Joseph lania says YouTube just switched
the stream on going live to a Fox News
channel
well that's not surprising make sure you
share this video be the notification you
want to see in the world because YouTube
certainly is pushing us down our
accident though remember because we were
watching the debate no no this is well
before the show no okay yeah the
accident in question was the monitors
got turned off there wasn't anything
having to do
yep yep but uh uh smash like button
share the video be the notification uh
if you guys share the video then we
don't got to rely on YouTube to notify
people and we can bypass censorship
America 76 says DeSantis is
consolidating establishment Rhino money
has distanced himself from Trump and is
gaining Rhino support Trump didn't take
a salary make of it what you will I I
don't think you can look at everything
DeSantis did right now in Florida and
think he's going to be bad you know I
think you look at everything he's doing
you're like he's kind of doing a good
job my only fear is would he would he
support War policy
he's got foreign policy experience
that's true but does is his position on
it going to be no new Wars no
intervention like Trump's probably not
so I I used to work for this
organization Think Tank and he was the
head of the Israel Victory project which
like he was the head of the caucus there
where it was like the Palestinians need
to admit defeat before we can even start
talking about like a two-state solution
or a one-state solution so I definitely
feel like if there was something going
on there he would definitely be involved
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
I was going to Super Chat about both
World War III and Civil War both
escalating at the same time it's going
to get crazy but since you talked about
Dylan doing transface I get to ask you
about the proper use of my Barbie pouch
I just want to point out two things
Mulvaney's saying like holding a big
handful of tampons and then saying
Barbie pouch I think is indicative of it
being a not not a serious and like
intended to to mock like Barbie pouch
and then as for the World War III Civil
War thing I think it actually is really
interesting and Ian made the good point
that the the Great War World War one was
for Russia a revolution and a and a
Civil War at the same time yeah so uh
the question about who would win a Civil
War in this country is often improperly
answered
let me ask you guys
who do you think would win if a civil
war broke out in the United States what
do you think left to the right
I think the right one what do you think
Luke
um
hard to tell um there's a lot of order
followers and and there's a lot of
Institutions controlled by the left but
the right is usually made up of a lot of
those order followers but they do follow
those orders all right what do you think
I don't know everyone's been weakened
but I think it would be the right they
just have more gun owners search
I think gun ownership is one thing
um I think that again like I mentioned
there's a lot of uh production different
parts of the US but I think probably the
right it just depends on who would Ally
because the thing about the left is they
have a lot of ports they have the
ability to then have things traded in
from Europe and Asia as well from both
sides of the country they'll get China
search nailed it yeah I think that was
that was that was trying to make okay so
I was thinking because we were like
limited to our own
amazing most people think that way right
and what you need to think about is
Russia on a Russian talk show a couple
months ago the pundit said America is
falling in a civil war the only thing we
need to figure out is which side we're
arming that's what's going to determine
so one of the big elements of the Civil
War was that the Confederates were
desperately trying to get recognition
from Europe
and that what was happening was uh the
the union was going into other countries
being like it's an internal dispute
don't worry you negotiate with us and
they're all like okay I guess it would
really come down to who is China going
to send the antibiotics too
what do they send the guns to yeah
China's if China's the manufacturing
base and and then the North had the
manufacturing China is going to be
sending machines tools replacement parts
and I feel like the right could like
make their own they're a little more
resourceful but I really think like
they're not making their own antibiotics
they're not making their own or vitamin
C yeah it depends on if we get tool up
production to make those things in time
that'd be the biggest yeah I see China's
supporting both sides they're like blow
each other up right
well right so what they would do is they
would choose they would they would want
want to sow disruption I don't think
that would mean they would fund both
sides I mean I think it would mean they
would fund the weaker so when people say
like oh the right's gonna win like what
if all history is like the right's gonna
win because they have the military they
have the training they have the passion
and then China specifically goes to the
port cities and arms them to the teeth
to create an even Battlefield to we gut
ourselves and and yeah and then they're
able to win right dylans of the world
will be like I don't want to break a
nail no I think at that point Dylan
drops the mockery of trans people and
says hey I'm gonna go leave the war
because I don't want to get killed and
Blair said Blair agrees with me though
like Blair yeah Blair agrees with you or
he's going to be a drone pilot I could
definitely see him kind of pushing
buttons let's kick some ass
we got we got one from Falcon laser Tim
did you see the video of an MSNBC
journalist asking a panel of trump
supporters about January 6. clay Travis
shared it on Twitter earlier today we
actually have it pulled up we'll talk
about this in the members only show
because it is it is insane this MSNBC
journalist doesn't even know what she's
talking about they're a lie she's like
but someone died on January 6 and
they're like yeah one protester and she
goes a cop died and they're like no no
unless it was a stroke and it was after
the fact and then I got a bad article
written about me from that one but
really yeah they said I I was saying in
a clubhouse space at one point in time
that like he died of natural causes and
one more time said that this is like
like right around them or before and so
like the Daily Dot wrote this horrible
article like Congressional staff or
blames Capitol Police for officer sit
next death and they still leave the
article up there and won't retract it
even though everything I said was
correct but well yeah there you go
they're the worst fake news that's
another element of Civil War you've got
ideologues who are lying all day every
day and don't care to fix it and then
their zealots believe it because it's
still there and no matter how much you
try to tell them they don't care they're
an occult
that's it's a cult man it's sad AI says
watch AMC's Rubicon it's one and only
season is that about Rome what's it
about
be cool if it was about Rome
bogus impression says for some reason
I'm imagining that when Russia attacks
America's infrastructure and
Manufacturing capabilities China is
going to be surprised when all the bombs
land in their factories because all we
know everything in America is made in
China
that's a good point yeah
let's see what we have here
e Rodriguez says I have to disagree with
the aforementioned YouTuber Communists
never cared for the poor they just hated
the rich over Orwell wrote about this in
one of his books I may have missed I'm
not trying to misrepresent the guy's
views the point was making is that the
Communists were all about masculinity
and strength as much as the fascists
were they just had a different view on
how to build a system
I think it was mostly about culture
Progressive versus traditional yeah
Pinochet helicopter tour says Tim when
it comes to Communism and socialism I
have a suggestion that is quite
effective though I'm not sure how to get
that many peanuts wait what were you
thinking I was going to say do we give
out packing like we give out like little
packs of peanuts to people that say like
vote on them
you like you throw you know people into
like vote GOP and because they eat a
couple of them peanuts are good man
oh Uncle Sam says speaking of looking
like what's up of looking like what's up
Sherry Oteri are we getting the Weekend
Update I kid beautiful and intelligent
cheers y'all
oh do you look do you look like Sherry
oh I don't know who shario Terry is SNL
I guess no I do I get the weirdest
people I don't know but thank you I
guess if he's trying to be nice some not
everybody's always that nice
okay
Michael Riley says these are the same
people saying Kyle shot black people I
bet antifa found someone with the same
name gave it to the media without doing
journalism exactly so initially when I
saw this report about the dude getting
attacked in Florida I did my digging and
the left is saying like oh he's a
fascist here's his name and I'm like
that picture you're showing is like a
fat guy and this is a thin guy and that
guy looks Mexican that kind of looks
Indian maybe it's same guy
I don't know not that I want it out on
our side or anything but we have a
couple like little grifters like there's
one in particular that says like they've
gotten hurt or attacked for wearing Maga
stuff and they haven't like because I
was there and saw that they didn't but
like Hamming it up yeah like I mean it
happens on both sides but like that this
is clearly a different story this guy's
like seriously isn't that such photos
it's awful Max Reddick says Tim I
watched that episode of electric dreams
last night you mentioned recently I'm
not going to lie I feel like that main
character no one listening to me what is
happening my friends if there is
anything you would spend money on to
watch Amazon despite the fact that we
all despise it watch kill all others on
uh from Electric dreams the show is
called electric dreams it is I believe
the last episode called kill all others
it will blow your mind seriously it's so
good
you will feel like the main character
so I see you guys writing it down have
you seen it no you guys should watch it
man I don't watch I I can't tell you
listen I don't watch like TV or a show
or anything the gist of it is where is
it oh Amazon Amazon Prime the show is
called electric dreams Philip K dick
Stories the last episode I think it's
the last episode I'll watch it because
you told me to
you need to watch it the gist of it is
it's this like factory worker guy and
he's watching a political debate it's a
well it's a political interview and the
president or the presidential candidate
says you know I'm I'm campaigning to to
reform schools to get better wages
obviously kill all others and we got to
get utility prices down and then he goes
whoa what they just what did they just
say and then everyone's just like oh I
don't care it's politics I'm not it's
not important and then slowly but surely
the the rhetoric is getting more and
more extreme he then sees like a woman
running screaming and people are chasing
her but I get her and they start beating
the crap out of her and he's like what
are you doing and they're like she's an
other she's an other and then he goes I
don't care stop the violence and they're
like why are you protecting her you're
an author too you just gotta watch it
it's so crazy like replace other with
like person who opposes child sex
changes and then you're like man you go
to your friends and family you tell them
like hey did you see what Joe Biden's
doing with gas and they're like I don't
care I don't care and then eventually
they're calling you the extremist on TV
like Joe Biden did
you gotta watch this episode you're
gonna be like whoa this is crazy dude
where is you
all right Heron gaming news says to add
to Luke's point of declining population
did you know there's a place in Italy
that Rings a church bell when a baby is
born
so there's like no one being born
otherwise the Bell would be ringing
non-stop I imagine right oh it's
probably a small village like they're
not
it's probably we're getting uh wrong a
lot we're getting down well the
population is dramatically being reduced
well because of low T and bad things in
our food and because men coddle women
and societies falling apart birth
control forever chemicals I could keep
going on father of those homes the other
thing is people need people who know
this at churches many of them
traditionally ring the bell every half
hour and that to me is I'm sorry that's
nuts that's crazy
so we're trying to set up shop in
Martinsburg uh West Virginia a physical
location and there's a church nearby
that rings the bell on the hour it's the
Chimes of the hour on the half an hour
banish the demons
I'm like
from the area I do not want the demons
to be banished from the area sure sure
I I'm not going to ask him to stop doing
it if they were there well before I was
I'm just pointing out that like that's
kind of a lot and so like you know we
have to do recordings periodically it's
impossible for us to do any kind of
Studio work in that City at all because
they ring the bell so often so you have
to be relatively far away from it or
build a soundproof studio and it's like
okay well you know it is what it is I I
think they they should if if they
traditionally do it I'm not going to try
and interfere with what they're doing I
just think it's like wow I just moved
like to a neighborhood in Philly and
they ring the bells on the hour and then
most half hours and then like they do
extra stuff when it's like service time
and stuff and I love it like it just
makes me feel like
somewhere I'm somewhere happy and safe I
mean it made a whole lot of sense back
when there were no clocks or anything
you're like I don't know what time it is
then you hear and you're like oh it's 3
30. yeah I like it yeah okay
but I get your problem
all right Scott Knowlton says Tim do you
see the story Luke reported on today
about the lady in the cop car getting
hit by a train no but I know that story
was from a couple weeks ago right uh the
dash cam footage came out recently and I
did a video on it I on my YouTube
channel one we are change and it's just
absolutely freaking crazy the police
officers in Colorado tied up handcuffed
a young woman put her in the back of a
squad car that they parked on train
tracks and they see a train coming and
they go run and they run away they
excuse me they served and protected very
well the situation by running out of the
way and let this poor woman be hit by a
train crazy uh absolutely insane case
the video is absolutely mind-boggling
and the officer who did everything paid
leave that's that's absolute criminality
to the highest degrees this is why I
can't negligence back to Blue yeah this
is why you can't so you trust anyone in
authority and you should always question
authority and try to hold accountable no
matter what the situation is and if this
is what police officers are doing
imagine what your politicians are doing
right
I mean these are just some bad cops man
just a few bad apples just you know just
Just One Bad Apple that you get a couple
to the other bad apples and then you
just yeah but look look as as it gets
worse and worse
any cop that had any semblance of Honor
or Talent is quitting right and that's
been happening over the past several
years so of course now it's you're even
just self-preservation because you don't
want to get charged or something totally
there's a video of that cop I think it's
in Portland OR Seattle and he pulls up
and he goes you guys won I quit I'm done
I'm quitting yeah and so then what do
you see you see videos like this now
don't get me wrong we've seen videos
like that well before there's any
demoralization of cops I'm just saying
expect to see it get way worse people
are asking in the comment section she
did live miraculously she survived but
she had some very serious injuries such
she had to do well what happened was you
know the train hit the car and she was
standing there and the train smacked
into her and then the train flipped over
and then crashed and she stood there
like like in the movie The report I read
was that she was screaming for her life
as police officers are running away from
her that's crazy yeah why did they park
the car on the train tracks it sounds
like they wanted to kill her real smart
yeah you know like I'm sorry dude did
you see the video how can you claim it's
an accident I played the video in the
beginning of my YouTube channel today on
on a video report today yeah it's crazy
I don't I don't see how you could argue
it was an accident I mean there's no
circumstance panicked no no no they
parked their car on the tracks then they
grab her then they bring her into the
car on the tracks then they leave the
corner tracks and walk away to her car
and then the train comes and go oh no
and they run away yep it's like dude
they were trying to kill her the video
is just crazy because you just see the
train coming you hear it from far away
who's recording this a dash cam and body
Cam and body cams from the police
officers the footage was released and
audit the audit is a is another YouTube
channel released the video as well
all right pinochets helicopter tours
says Tim look into tiv or tendency for
interpersonal victimhood a new
personality construct doctors have
studied explains the motivations of
squeaky Wheels
well
just got to build a fort in the middle
of nowhere and be self-sufficient
Alberto cheaprez says Tim give Mary a
political show would love to see her
angry rants I don't get angry about
politics I don't let those things anger
me
that's me I just don't get angry on this
show I let stupid celebrities get me
angry
yeah you gotta check out that show
John morafa says forget Red Wave forget
red tsunami red megadon megadon baby
bring it on what is that redmageddon oh
redmageddon oh man I went right over my
head
redmageddon no I read great flood it's
it's like the tsunamis it's the the wave
is gonna be so big Democrats got to
build an ark you know what I'm saying
great flight they're letting us win I
think it's what they're gonna let us
start they're I'm telling you it's going
to be my little prediction I mean it
really does feel like Democrats are
sabotaging on purpose they were they
were there the Veritas theater that came
out where it's Katie hobbs's twin sister
saying the Democrats are funding the
more extreme Republicans
yeah
I guess I don't know what they're
planning
but whatever
Cosmic surgeon says is it already
criminal to write and publish the leak
no it's not
journalists they're allowed to report on
this stuff the Pentagon papers the
Afghan war logs
etc etc uh project Veritas is a really
good example look how much project
Veritas receives in leaks uh Wikileaks
was very much the same they were
journalists people would send them
secure files they would blow the whistle
or just leak stuff and then Wikileaks
would release and report on it and
Wikileaks even editorialized I'll
criticize them for some of the
editorialization but they're journalist
same as anybody else and that's it I got
a quick question for you real quick do
you think that that there was a ton of
leaks coming out of the Trump
Administration do you think that there's
as many leaks coming out of the Biden
Administration but the media doesn't
take it and pick them up or do you think
that there's more and they're more
disciplined I think there's probably
more leaks and the media won't touch
them yeah because the Biden the Trump
administration had there there were
there was
a certain degree of
well you know what maybe it is
comparable because there there's there's
animosity across the board but I think
the reason I would say that there may be
more of Biden is that his insanity and
incompetence that's what I'm saying he's
got to be like bumping into walls
forgetting things like yelling and
acting out and there's nothing and it's
not even it's like
right with Trump people are angry and
don't like him so they're looking for
things with Biden you can't avoid these
things certainly someone said you know I
was at the White House today I was just
bringing papers from one room I saw
Biden trip and fall you know and and
those are the kind of things where
they're where you'd think they did they
leak out they don't right the media
won't report on it they're probably
going well nobody really cares about
that stuff he's running around naked
again trying to catch some kind of dog
pooping everywhere
Doc Holliday says I love what Trump said
boo hoo hoo well sure yeah whatever
he then said just unsubscribe from Luke
uncensored that's fine that's okay you
go right ahead and do whatever you want
you're a free person I'm gonna vote for
Trump
but but would you subscribe what would
you be cheering on if if Biden was doing
the same exact thing to project Veritas
ask yourself that question and then kind
of think about that here's the thing
right that's that's the point right
there is is with these leaks coming out
that Veritas gets especially Ashley
Biden's diary in the FBI raid on Project
Veritas what Trump said was trash yeah
well here's my thing about like the
followers on following you and stuff
right after
um you know the election results came
out and it was you know for Biden and
not Trump and everybody's like oh and
there was like this big upper I said on
Instagram or somewhere I was like Hey
guys like you know what let's just
support our president let's all show up
on Biden's inauguration with our Mega
hats and like whatever only because I've
been around so long that I know that
these things are not easily overturned
people are like we would never want you
in our Corner you're not a fighter I'm
like what you're not a real Trump fan I
was like are you kidding me if you are
not like if you don't have this like
blind Allegiance all of a sudden they're
like swearing you off God forbid you
have your own brain and you have
something different to say something I
don't love Trump I just know how corrupt
the system is and that it was never
going to work out in his favor so now
you're just gonna say I'm not a fighter
I'm a quitter worshiping any politician
is just cringe and and if you think one
person's going to solve all your
problems you're not paying attention the
cringiest thing that really annoyed the
crap out of me was the after the
election people were like March 3rd the
real day Trump's coming back and then
April 17th the real day and I'm like
stop it's not it's not real and then and
then it took like a year before people
finally stopped saying that the arrests
were coming and I'm just like and so
that's the thing about the fraud
narrative is that people don't
understand that it's shifted
dramatically over the past two years
initially the whole narrative was very
much like servers and Chinese ballots
and like one thing that all of that
stuff isn't true I'm not saying that
like the that there wasn't a significant
amount of fraud to overturn the election
there's just no way to prove it and
there was no way they were going to let
you prove it and if you even look at the
way absentee mail and ballots are done
it comes in and outer envelope right
then it comes with another one that you
sign and then the paper one once they
separate those you can never match them
back up but they don't know who did it
it's never going to be provable that's
not even the issue at all the problem
with all of that stuff is that certainly
the provability the the year of
abandoning it the the all the reports
and research and everything that we've
even talked about on this show going
back to when it it all LED nowhere and
now what you have is you have like
Dinesh D'Souza and you have like the
ballot harvesting stuff which is always
what we talked about the shadow campaign
to save the election from Time Magazine
the procedure and policies and those
changes that actually had a huge impact
and the month-long voting that's
happening now those are things that need
to be sued over and you need to go to
court to challenge the procedure in the
policy but anyway my point is not to
rehash all that stuff it's that some
people are just so fervent that they
believed all of that and it's just like
come on man look Trump's a guy I think
Trump's pretty good I think no new Wars
was absolutely incredible the best
response we got in the super chats when
Dave Smith was here was these problems
were created over 100 years we won't end
them overnight and I'm like that's
that's ABS absolutely like a voting for
a president that didn't start any wars
and actually was working towards peace
is like as good as we're getting right
now if we're Advanced I mean imagine
you're at one end of a football field
and you've got to get to the other side
and so you're waiting for someone who
can throw you a hundred yards versus
just taking one step at a time
so what's your choice I'm going to stand
right here until someone can toss me
that full hundred you're a human you
weigh too much it's never going to
happen you can't move the monolith like
that I mean I'm going in the opposite
direction according to my opinion and
you got to stop worshiping worshiping no
nutritions and start believing in
yourself no new Wars is the opposite
direction he almost got us into war with
almost Syria with Iran he bombed a
country he went further than Barack
Obama did with his foreign policy
especially when it came to Ukraine I
like that better though right he was
unpredictable you know that you have
people like this and Biden Putin would
have never like encroached on Ukraine at
troubles Trump was getting our troops
out of Syria and Afghanistan I'm not
saying he's perfect he was not getting
any troops out of nowhere like he he
talked a good game but he got John
Bolton he did it their troops are still
there John Bolton yeah right
200 on the record but how many special
ops how many other drones are flying
overhead how many other military
operations were still going on there you
can't accept is like I said taking one
step in the right direction you can't
tell me that no new Wars is going the
wrong direction okay Luke you want more
war at least one new war that's right
limited proxy war okay he didn't
officially declare a war but so didn't
Barack Obama Barack Obama didn't
officially declare a war you're playing
semantics here okay but he did did he
but he did finance a whole bunch of
rebels he did finance a whole bunch of
uh overthrows right so that the argument
is still there some parts
for actually doing something bombing
other countries it's utopian dude yes it
is you don't bomb a country because your
daughter cries okay
this is a straw man argument that I
didn't make the point I made Abraham
Accords and the peace deals he bought
off countries that's the Abraham reports
so what it didn't amount to any kind of
repurchase fine if we're getting our if
he's trying to get our shirts out of
here it's just like hey we'll give you a
little bit of money let Israel fly in
here he's like okay cool are we working
how do you how do you have your foreign
policy wise are we worse off now
absolutely absolutely I like light years
right was he the best one that we've had
in years as far as foreign policy is
concerned as far as more impossible okay
I don't know no no no I don't know I I I
think that's okay
better than foreign policy Bill Clinton
no not Obama George W bush no Reagan all
of them suck all of them all of them all
of them all of them took money that we
didn't have and then I printed it and
gave it to the military discount complex
giving money to Saudi Arabia to commit
the human human atrocities in Yemen
answer the question what's the question
who was better than Trump on foreign
policy I can't think of I think I I
think all the foreign policy has been
atrocious okay
I can't look at dog crap be like that
that that's something
I'm gonna I'm gonna pause you right
there and say I think you're being
disingenuous I can look at a pile of dog
diarrhea and be like that's
substantially worse on my carpet than
that thick corn turd okay but but let's
let's be let's be honest here we're
arguing about dog [ __ ] right listen so
it's all it's all dogcraft if I had a
dog we agree on that that every year
would crap on my carpet and it was a
variety of diarrhea and then one day all
of a sudden it's thick corn crap I go
well it's still bad but we're moving in
the right Direction and it's easier to
clean up that's my point is you can you
can pick it right up and be a Lightroom
yeah you can well it depends on what the
dog also had look we're playing but
we're playing I appreciate the debate
and I appreciate the conversation
there's a lot of things that that we
should be of course discussing when it
comes to this foreign policy is
extremely important I think he he could
have done a way better job uh nobody's
really disagreeing with that but he's
absolutely the best that we've had his
drone policy says military industrial
complex spending him giving weapons to
Saudi Arabia committing the atrocities
in Yemen uh the conflicts with Iran the
conflict with Syria the course you're
making excuses for the same policies
that that Obama was doing that he
continued so it's like like I said
you're at you're at the end you're in
the end zone of a football field and
Luke sang because we're not getting
[Music]
Obama did what's the difference
so what's the difference
getting our troops out of Syria citing
the deadline for for getting out of
Afghanistan Crossing into the DMZ in
North Korea sending weapons to Ukraine
you can argue is bad but it was getting
us out of the conflict and saying it's
you now you do it telling NATO to pay
their fair share Donald Trump was very
much like I don't understand why we're
at war in these places and when he tried
to get all of our troops out of Syria
every last one of them the the executive
branch lied to the American people and
they lied to Trump to keep secret troops
on the ground it's insane I'll be
intellectually honest I concede on North
Korea I concede on NATO spending even
though he pushed for it but at the same
time the effects weren't there as he was
sending lethal weapons in escalating
this is my point but I concede on North
Korea 100 my point is not that Donald
Trump came in with a magic wand and
saved the world my point is it's the
best foreign policy I've seen in my life
from a president that doesn't mean it's
good it means it was moving in the right
direction it was pulling things back
even if it was one inch on a football
field it is better and if and and when
Tulsi so Tulsi gabbard endorses Biden I
don't buy it Tulsi gabbard knows the
problems of the regime change War it was
her campaign thing it's one of the
things I focus on and Donald Trump is
like I'm gonna I promised this I'm gonna
try and make it happen the increase in
drone strikes it's bad for a lot of
reasons but it was happening because we
were pulling our our operations out of
the Middle East and we didn't want the
Taliban and other groups like Isis to
storm he made arguments about killing
civilians and he made an argument
jailing journalists it's bad yes but he
also he also made sure that there was no
transparency with his drone program with
Obama we know how many people he bombed
we know he bombed weddings we know he
bombed hospitals under Trump we don't
know because Trump classified a lot of
that information and gave the power to
drop to drone bomb people into and to
assassinate them through to the Pentagon
which is crazy you're you're not arguing
in the same area that I'm arguing I'm
arguing that we know Trump did bad
things but it was to a much lesser
degree than we've seen from any other
president in the past in my lifetime
debatable we're on a scale here uh well
who's on par
like there's nobody better you can't
name look I'm not saying I can't I know
but but we're not we're not really
talking about a lot of things here let's
what's my favorite part then this is
like the most interesting I like when it
gets heated it should get heated
conversation let's grab one more and
then uh uh and then I'm gonna warm up
because it's freezing in here and the
hips are cold and then we'll go to the
numbers only James Eaton says my family
didn't join the fight until the union
graped the women in Newmarket VA it was
never a fight for slaves it was a moral
war against Northern aggression next is
moral War to save the kids there's a lot
to break down there let's definitely
talk about the members only because I'm
gonna go ham because I was like that's a
lot I've been reading a lot of Civil War
stuff over the past couple years
obviously there's a drinking game
whatever Temple says Civil War and then
going to Gettysburg and actually going
through everything and we and not only
that but over the past weekend uh two
weeks ago I went down the the CNO Canal
reading all about everything was going
on crazy awesome stuff to read
um horrifying history
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel would you kindly smash that like
button become a member at timcast.com
we're going to talk a lot about all of
this stuff because we had this clip from
January 6. I want to talk about Civil
War I want to go I want to I want to go
off on all of this stuff about you know
things I'm learning so that'll be at
timcast.com at about 11. you can follow
the show at Tim cast IRL you can follow
me at timcast Lisa do you want to shout
anything out no nothing you can just
find me at Lisa Elizabeth on Twitter I
guess that's where I'm most active right
now Lisa that was great thank you so
much for coming on thanks for having me
if you want to know what I really think
you could go on Luke uncensored.com and
if you think my my comments about Donald
Trump or spicy wait until what I said
about Ben Shapiro today lukeansensor.com
I love the comments I'm always in the
comment section and if you think the
negative comments hurt me you have no
idea they feel me I love them I love the
debate I love the discussion let's let's
challenge ourselves as much as we can
right now and and hey if you think I'm
wrong show me the evidence let's let's
actually debate this let's actually have
an honest conversation about this I love
it and I love being able to express
these ideas thank you so much for having
ghost girl well if you're tired of
talking about dog crap and Civil War
then maybe subscribe to pop culture
crisis on YouTube we go live Monday
through Friday 3 P.M we talk about fun
things like movies celebrities TV shows
all of that entertainment news we have
fun over there
um if you send a super chat you can
shoot money at us it's fun so uh go
subscribe over there and if you want to
see pictures of me on the internet then
you can follow me on Instagram at
maryarchived if you want to hear my
inane thoughts you can follow me on
Twitter also at Mary archived you know
we never talked about the Katy Perry I
think let's talk about that
is wigging out yeah whether it was like
blue or not yeah art deal I hope you
guys like that one that was pretty wild
the chat with spicy anyways I'll read it
tomorrow you leave your chest up so I
can read them later
they're all on there okay good there's a
lot I'm excited I'm in there I like the
bad ones too I I find like the one good
one and I hang on to that one the whole
time so I don't care about the bad one
hey comments are funny yeah I agree
great great I love it all right
everybody head over to timcast.com
become a member and we'll see y'all
there
cheers